So Leute, ich müsste wieder da sein, sagt mir mal ob ich wieder da bin, ich sehs noch
nicht, weil ich mein Streamingrechner noch nicht hochgefahren hab.
Ja, ok, sehr schön.
Das ist ein höchst professioneller Stream heute.
Ok, ich muss mal mein Streamingrechner hochfahren.
Oh, jetzt hab ich meine Headsetverlänger runtergeschmissen.
So, ok, ich hoffe da startet jetzt alles.
So, the struggle is real, so, ok, der Streamingrechner startet, ey, ich glaub der Streamingrechner
will Updates machen, aber ich dachte, das könnte doch funktionieren, meine Güte, aber schön
das, die Elgato chillt sich im Bios ein ab, alles, alles gut, Bios chillzor.
So, und wenn jetzt mein Streamingrechner noch starten würde, also mein, es ist ja noch gar
nicht mein Streamingrechner, der Rechner für Vorschau und Gedöns.
Ok, er ist gestartet, sehr schön, guck mal, sehr pock, sehr pockig ist das, so, Windows
wurde nicht richtig beendet, na mach Witz, hä, wobei, warum, achso, weil ich den falschen
Rechner eben auch noch resettet hab, vor lauter Bluescreen, ich hab eben an falschen Rechner
Reset gedrückt, ja, der Rechner von dem ich streame ist abgekackt und ich hab den anderen
auch noch neu gestartet.
Ok, ich glaube jetzt haben wir's, es funktioniert, alles wieder da und es lebt, ok, sehr gut,
Lautstärke passt, lauter können, Ticken runter machen, ok, alles gut, ich hab einen USB Stick,
ich hab das Proxmox ISO drauf, wir haben die Elgato Capture Card mit Zeugs, das müsste
das jetzt eigentlich im Vollbild machen, sobald ich, ja, sehr schön, nice, funktioniert.
Ok Leute, ihr könnt euch jetzt aussuchen, wollen wir jetzt wirklich schnell anfangen
oder soll ich jetzt noch die NVMe SSD dran machen, ich hätt nämlich noch eine schlinknormale
500G SSD, ich glaub das tut's auch, oder, besser als dass ich die jetzt noch auspacke,
schließe, guck aufs funktioniert, mein Chat Tool muss ich starten, genau, Dream4M, Test,
funktioniert, hier, da sind wir wieder, längst gestartet, Ding hier gestartet und jetzt müssen
wir noch mein Poggers Tool anmachen, mein Pepega Board Chat Tool und dann ist's gut,
hört ihr eigentlich im Hintergrund wie das Netzteil klappert, das übelt's im Arsch,
also falls man das nicht erkannt hat bei der quasi nahezu perfekten Imitation, das war
ich eben, der das Netzteil nachgemacht hat, aber ihr hört das Netzteil nicht, na, was
ist mit dem Programm virtualisiert, alles was du willst, das ist ein Webinterface, äh,
das ist ein Hypervisor mit Webinterface, also ein bisschen was wie ESX, du kannst einfach
alles virtualisieren, kannst Linus Container oder vollwertige VMs machen, das ganze schön
gemanagt über Webinterface, ohne Zuschauer, ja, hätt ich's eben nicht verkackt und der
Rechner wär abgeschissen, hätt ich wahrscheinlich jetzt sogar wieder ein bisschen mehr schon,
aber ich find's nice, dass so viele am Start sind wieder, unter der Woche, gut, ist mein
Board jetzt gestartet, fangen wir an, ja, ok, Chat Tool gestartet, alles gut, kannst du
mal PCI Paththrough testen, könnten wir machen, komm, PCI Express, Slot drauf, aber jetzt
installieren wir den Mist erstmal, auf geht's, Fullscreen, ähm, es kann jetzt sein, dass
ich nicht ordentlich auf Chat und alles reagieren kann, weil ich muss meine Tastatur und Zeug
jetzt mal um, Tastatur zumindest umstöpseln, an hier die andere Kiste, wobei, ja, dafür
hab ich ja eigentlich mal ne Vorschau, ne, genau, das mit dem Mikrotik-Router gucken
wir dann zum Schluss heute nochmal, oder nachher, ok, USB hab ich hier, dann, dann, geh ich
auf die Erd und stöpseln mal, Tastatur an, und schauen wir mal, ähm, Tastatur, zack,
Tastatur, geht ran, USB immer falsch rum, ne, nie richtig rum, USB, mal gucken, ob die
Tastatur jetzt geht, es sollte sich jetzt was im BIOS bewegen gleich, äh, bewegt sich
im BIOS aber nix, warum bewegt sich da im BIOS nix, oder im BIOS, will das natürlich
die coolen Leute sagen, na gut, an meiner Vorschau kann es ja schlecht liegen, wir starten
mal neu, also hier den Rechner, was denn das für ein kack Netzteil, hat das kein Schalter
doch, flop, und wieder an, und hoffentlich erkennt er jetzt die Tastatur, die Uhrzeit
läuft ja, PS2 Tastatur, äh, das hat keinen PS2 Anschluss, das Ding, ich hab keine PS2
Tastatur hier, ja, blablabla, gehen wir mal ins BIOS, aaah, Funst, ok, nice, jetzt brauch
ich noch ne, brauch ich noch ne SSD und nen SATA, das Leute, das wird viel lustiger, wenn
ich mir ähm, demnächst mal hier ne Ecke mit Tisch und so gemacht hab, dass man den Kram
zumindest auch sieht, aber viel besser, so, SSD Karte anstöpseln, mal ausmachen, SSD
anstöpseln, zack, zack SATA Stromversorgung anstöpseln, geht ran, SATA Stromversorgung
hat man auch aus Prinzip immer falsch rum, so, und das ganze, wieder an, ok, und jetzt
sollte ich eigentlich den Krampel installieren können, im BIOS funneln wir gar nicht großartig
rum, im BIOS funneln wir gar nicht großartig rum, ähm, wir gehen einfach direkt ins Bootmenü
und gucken, dass wir den Kram booten können, ey, hat schon von alleine gebootet, das ist
ja Massive POG, ok, install Proxmox ME, jawoll, ja, wir haben so ein bisschen so 1-2 Sekunden
Lack von Tastatur zu Bildschirm, weil das ist ja noch die alte Elgato Capture Card,
die ich hier dran habe, über USB, ach so, Moment Leute, eine Netzwerkerkarte, die sollte
ich auch noch einstöpseln, ne, so, Netzwerkkabel, so, ja, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ja, Netzwerkkabel, äh, wir brechen den Kram nochmal ab oder wir starten nochmal neu, kann
man dem Ding hier irgendwie sagen, mach mal nur, mach mal nur Fullscreen, nur Fullscreen
please, geht das, nicht erst dieses Rumgelegge Fullscreen, sondern immer Fullscreen, ok,
wir brechen das nochmal ab und starten neu, dass er sich eine IP holen kann, ich klicke
jetzt, ich klicke doch jetzt nicht die komischen Lizenzbedingungen durch, soll ich mich rollen
oder was, brauch ich zum installieren ernsthaft eine Maus, ernsthaft, hast du denn eine Maus
für, oder seht ihr irgendwo, wo ich hier gelandet bin, ich starte jetzt nochmal neu,
dass sich das Ding eine IP zieht, ich meine, ich kann einfach meine Maus anschließen,
ich meine, ernsthaft, den Installer brauchen wir, dass man eine Maus braucht, das wäre
schon fail, das wäre schon fail, schauen wir mal, ja, please, DHCP, come on bra, DHCP,
DHCP, willst du mich verarschen, warum kannst du denn jetzt bei DHCP ziehen, ach, das ist
Netboot, wenn das Netboot nicht funktioniert, ist ja logisch, auf time dich mal out, kann
man nicht escape drücken oder so, ach, ok, doch, time dich mal out, so, ok, install Proxmox,
ve, jawoll, Proxmox braucht doch noch CD, ne, ich denke mal net, ok, wir haben die Platte
gefunden, ne, doch, oder, haben wir Platte gefunden, DHCP discover, go go, ja, irgendwie
2127 oder so hat er gefunden, was bietet Proxmox 6 für coole Neuerungen, haben wir
uns gerade angeguckt, ich kann das leider nicht umschalten, weil ich hab meine Tastatur,
meine Tastatur am Installer dran, ok, ich mach jetzt einfach mal auf gut Glück, I agree,
ok, funktioniert nicht, sag mal, man muss doch mit dem Tab, I agree, braucht man da
allen Ernstes eine Maus für, I agree, ne, normalerweise geht das mit Tab, aber, ich
mein, ihr seht ja, ich, ich tabbe hier schon ne ganze, ne ganze Weile und ich seh jetzt
da nix, ehrlich gesagt, ich drück jetzt einfach mal abwechselnd Tab, Enter, Tab, Enter, Tab,
aber, ähm, dann schließe ich halt noch ne Maus an, ich schließe jetzt noch ne Maus
an, so, Eats, schließen wir noch ne Maus an, von Linux Installer muss ich ne Maus für
anschließen, äh, huge, so, ha, Maus, Maus bewegen wird natürlich ein bisschen kacke
mit zwei Sekunden leck, ne, huge precision hier, ok, also, 500G SSD, jawoll, passt, please
verify installation, tage, blblblblblbl, alles gut, next, ach ne, Moment, wir wollen
mal gucken, was, was haben wir für Optionen, äh, Ext4, ne, wow, ZFS, ZFS, Raid, ja, gut,
äh, Raid 1, ähm, Raid 1 mit nur einer Platte wird ein bisschen schwierig, ne, erste Seite
vom Installer, ja, grausam, ähm, na gut, dann machen wir einfach ZFS Raid 0, ich mein,
ZFS Raid 0 mit einer Platte ist zwar kein Raid 0, aber, mein, wir können's einfach
mal machen, ne, Kamikaze Raid, alter, meine Mausbewegung ist diese Wahnsinns, ja, was,
Wahnsinns, aim, äh, keyboard layout, Germany, na gut, ähm, hoffentlich ist das Webinterface
nicht deutsch, Passwort, wahnsinnig secure, wieder 1,2,3,4,5,6, 1,2,3,4,5,6, mail example
Punkt invalid, klingt richtig gut, ah, huge debate, mail at example.com, mail, mail, blubblubblubblub,
perfekt, next, mail Punkt valid, haha, das ist ein nicer Witz, huge, äh, ja, mit domain
name ist mir egal, 50, 50 passt, next, okay, proxmox.local.woblords, ha, das funktioniert
natürlich, ist ja auch logisch, ne, ne, ordentliche Domain funktioniert nicht, aber Punkt Woblords,
das funktioniert, okay, es installt, du kannst dir die Domain example.com nicht kaufen, weil
definiert ist, dass alles an example.com, äh, in der Tonne landet, warum, warum, das
Elgato Ding, ne, das tut jetzt ja so, als hätte ich Mausbewegungen, die dafür sorgen,
dass, dass, dass aktiv wird und eingeplant wird, die Maus habe ich überhaupt nicht dran,
die ist am anderen Rechner, also ich kann überhaupt keine Mausbewegungen machen auf
der Kiste, frag mich nicht, warum die unbedingt ne Domain haben wollen, ich mein, irgendwas
muss da angeben, ja, aber die meisten nehmen dann den Default Ding, so irgendwie was, local
LAN oder, oder, oder local domain Punkt irgendwas oder so, das ist eigentlich vollkommen wurscht,
wenn du ne Domain lokal hast, oder wenn du lokalen DNS betreibst, oder hast ne Domain,
dann kann man die einstellen, aber, ich hab ne Domain für mein Helmautomatisierungszeug
gekauft, eine Punkt Haus Domain, aber die will ich jetzt hier nicht eintragen, local
Haus Punkt local, irgendwie sowas blödsinniges, ja, so, wenns installiert ist, stöpsel ich
wieder alles um und wir gehen über das Web-Interface drauf, easy, Punkt Haus, ne, ne, Punkt Haus
auf Deutsch, easy, ja, sowas wie mein Punkt Haus, genau, allerdings war das schon belegt,
aber, ich
Make system bootable. Na dann GLHF. Ich bewege meine Maus nicht, Elgato. Ich kann meine Maus
nicht bewegen, die ist nicht dran. Was unterscheidet ESXi und Proxmox, also von der technischen
Sicht? Naja, das eine ist ESX und das andere ist ein Linux mit KVM. Also der Hypervisor
ist ein ganz anderer. Geboot, mal gucken ob es funktioniert. Okay, ich habe lange Zeit
bekommen meine CD zu removeen. Hey, es bootet. Oh Pog Airs. Da steht sogar die IP. 2.127.8006.
Da kann ich jetzt nämlich meine Tastatur und meine Maus endlich wieder umstöpseln, dass
ich den Rechner wieder richtig bedienen kann. So, komm her. Maus da dran. Und Tastatur.
So, endlich wieder. Okay, also 2.127. 1.27 was? 8006. HTTPS. Ach so. Okay, ich habe jetzt
noch einen. Ach so. Sagt es doch gleich. QChat. Da ist es. Nice. Venix, guck einfach mal im
Archiv wo wir das geflasht haben. Du brauchst eigentlich nur einen Raspberry oder du brauchst
irgendeine Linux Kiste mit WLAN, dass es funktioniert. Ich würde dir einen Raspberry empfehlen,
den kann man immer gebrauchen und viele haben auch schon einen. Okay, Username, Admin, Passwort
1.2.3.4.5.6. Linux bla. Login. Wobei, ist es überhaupt Admin? Was ist denn der Default?
Sorry, egal. Brauche ich nicht. Geht auch so. Okay, nice. Also, wir haben hier unseren
lokalen Node, der eine leere Festplatte hat, will er uns wahrscheinlich sagen. Das ist
der Storage Pool, vermute ich mal. Also bei VMware heißt das Storage Pool. Wir haben
hier lokal, ZFS, Bladings. Okay, das ist quasi unser Cluster Eintrag. So, ich würde sagen,
jetzt machen wir mal was. Jetzt starten wir da mal einen Ubuntu Server oder sowas, starten
wir da jetzt mal drauf. Oder hat jemand einen Vorschlag? Was wollen wir ausprobieren für
eine VM? Wir machen einen Ubuntu, sorry, Ubuntu, Ubuntu. Jaja, stimmt ja, richtig. Wir machen
mal ein Ubuntu Beta 19 Beta. Creepy SD. Können wir tatsächlich mal machen? Debian. Debian
PC Part 2. Hab ich ja nie gemacht, Debian. Nehmen wir einen Container. Nein, erstmal
machen wir eine ordentliche VM. Wir könnten Windows installieren in der VM. Das war übelst
mit der. Windows. Windows 95 ISO. Das machen wir jetzt. Wen ist denn jetzt in Windows 95
da drauf? Wenn ich den ISO finde. Genau, Giga, Giga, erzähl uns mal, wo es das ISO gibt.
Da, BÄM, Windows 95 ISO. Windows, wer wollte nicht schon immer mal Windows 95 installieren
da drauf? Reactor S könnten wir auch machen. So, ok, wie linken wir hier eine VM an? Also
sollte das mit Windows 95 nicht funktionieren, werden wir mal ein Deluxe installieren, weil
da wissen wir wenigstens, wenn es nicht funktioniert, dass irgendetwas an Proxmox liegt. Ok, wie
linken wir jetzt eine VM an? Hier, was haben wir da? Create VM, Create Container. Wie create
mal Container? Was kann man da auswählen? Note Name, Proxmox, worauf es läuft. Container
IT lassen wir Standard. Test, Resource Pool. Brauchen wir nix. Passtwort. So. Template,
was haben wir zur Auswahl? Storage, Template. Wie kriege ich da Templates rein? Wie kriege
ich da Container Templates rein? Hm, muss ich später nochmal gucken. Invalib vz-template-iso
muss das rein, ok. Storage. Man kann die ISOs doch garantiert auch irgendwie über das
Web-Interface hochladen. Ok, Windows 95 C. Create VM. VM ID. Windows 95. Use Storage
Local. Achso. Use Physical Media. Nee, können wir nicht machen. Aber man kanns, ok, man
kanns nicht über das Web-Interface mounten. Das ist schonmal Z. Storage. Disk Image Container.
ISO Image. Wie kriege ich da jetzt was drauf? Wir, wir, wir tracken und droppen jetzt einfach
mal, mal gucken, was passiert. Windows. Äh, nein. Nein, nein, nein, so funktioniert das
schonmal nicht. Was im Server-View am linken Rand? Ok Leute, ich glaub ihr, äh, hallo,
wo ist mein Proxmox hin? Wir machen uns das mal da als Link hin. Auf die Node Proxmox und
Landstorage auswählen. Node Proxmox. Und jetzt Disks. Directory. Disks. Was macht Proxmox
genau anders als OpenStack? Hatte bis dato nur Letzteres benutzt. Äh, ich hab Proxmox
letztes Mal vor 3 oder 2 oder 3 Versionen verwendet. Aufklappen links. Ah, hier oder
was? Ah. Ah, da. Und wo muss das jetzt rein? Local oder Local? ZFS. Local. Upload. Select
File. Ok. Downloads Windows 95. Zack. Upload. Weiß jemand, ob man da, ähm, die Standard
LXD, LXC Ubuntu-Images und so verwenden kann für die Container? Ok, wir haben ein Windows
95 ISO. POG. Jetzt können wir eine VM anlegen. Create VM. Blablabla. Resource Pool. Brauchen
wir nicht. Name. Windows 95. 777 Follower. Sehr nice. Danke für die Follows. Da ist
es. Das Windows 95 ISO. Das ist kein Linux. Das ist ein Windows. Und zwar ein Windows.
Ja. Ein Windows 2000. Was anderes kann man da gar nicht mehr auswählen. Ähm, ok, was
kriegt es denn? Jaja, alles. Da müssen wir irgendwas Altes auswählen, was der kann.
Und kein SCSI Controller bitte. Fuck, das läuft doch nie oder Windows? Wir lassen einfach
mal alles Default. IDE. IDE ist schon mal gut für Windows 95. 32G ist auch mehr als genug
für Windows 95. TPU reicht eine auch, äh, dicke. Und 512 reicht für Windows, Windows
auch. Wir machen's mal kurz, wir machen Windows 95 mal ohne Network Device. Ich will mit Windows
95 nicht ins Internet. Nee, komm, wir gehen ins Internet. Wir gehen ins Internet mit Windows
95. YOLO. Next. Finish. Jetzt bin ich ja mal echt gespannt, ob das funktioniert. Konsole.
Achso, Start erstmal, ne. Und jetzt. Nochmal Start. Wow. Was? Was ist das? Was ist das?
Was? Was hast du für Schmerzen? Ah! Ähm, ok, ich muss nochmal ins BIOS. Ich muss nochmal
ins BIOS, äh, Hardware Virtualisierung einschalten. Disable VM in Configuration. Dann macht er
das ohne oder was? VM Configuration. Da bin ich ja drinne. Options. Was muss ich hier deaktivieren?
Ah, hier. Hardware Virtualisation Support. Enabled. Aus. Das ist für Windows 95 wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mal so schlecht. Ist es eigentlich rein theoretisch möglich, BIOS Settings vom
OS auszuändern? Joa, theoretisch geht das schon. Ok, jetzt Start. Oh, es startet. Huge. Ich
hab jetzt eigentlich gehofft, es bootet von CD. Boot Menü. Escape. CD. Warum bootet er
nicht von CD? Ist die CD vielleicht nicht gemounted? Ok, CD Laufwerk. Gemounted. Could
not read vom CD-ROM. Tja. Grip. Grip würde ich sagen. Geht nicht. Obwohl wir das richtige
ISO haben. FeelsBatman. Das hat mir sicher eine Boot-Order. Ich habe jetzt aber explizit
die DVD ausgewählt. Ich glaube wir gehen mal ins BIOS. Ist das so EFI-Boot? Das könnte
tatsächlich sogar sein. Dann geht natürlich Windows 95 nicht. Weil, das wird wahrscheinlich
nicht standardmäßig EFI-Boot sein, wenn ich gesagt habe Windows 2000. Tja, wo, wo
könnte man das jetzt einstellen? Ich sehe hier auch von UEFI ehrlich gesagt nichts.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass der da standardmäßig UEFI-Boot versucht. Man kann ja da auch nichts
großartig einstellen. OS-Type kann man einstellen. Da haben wir ja schon eingestellt Windows
2000. Das ist das Niedrigste was geht. Boot-Order. CD-ROM. Hotplug. Omegalol. Das machen wir mal
aus. Man weiß ja nie. Hardware-Virtualisation haben wir ausgeschaltet. Nä. Mehr kann man
da glaube ich nicht machen. Ok, wir probieren es nochmal. Wir rebooten jetzt und schalten
BIOS-Hardware-Virtualisierung ein. Was unter Hardware ist das gelistet? Nä, das ist Default,
das ist kein UEFI-Boot. Der findet bestimmt, wobei das Booten ist noch eine Proxmox-Geschichte,
das hat noch nichts mit Windows zu tun. Nä. Ich glaube der mag kein Windows 95 starten.
Fields-Batman. Ich starte. Macht man jetzt hier aus? Stopp. Jop. Oder nicht? Ich will
hart ausschalten. Will ausschalten. Ah, jetzt hat er ausgeschaltet. Ich start nochmal neu.
Start. Grund- und Read vom CD-ROM. Ja, vielleicht ist das ISO auch kaputt. Egal, probieren wir
was anderes. Windows XP ISO. Jeden Stream kommt was komplett anderes dran, nötig unbedingt.
Windows XP ISO. Wo gibt es denn Windows XP ISO? ISO. GIF. Test-Fest im Moment. Es gab
Windows XP x64. Wir starten jetzt auf jeden Fall mal neu und schalten im BIOS die Virtualisierung
ein. Das machen wir jetzt. Da schalten wir hier in den Optionen, schalten wir noch KVM-Virtualisierung
wieder auf Yes und machen das Ding aus. Gehen wir mal hier Elgato-mäßig wieder rein und
Rebooten das Ding. Muss ich die Tastatur wieder umstellen. Achso, vielleicht soll ich mal
hier. Wir gehen jetzt mal ins BIOS. BIOS. Ah, äh, RUT. Liegt an der Hardware-Virtualisierung.
Ah, ok. Ja, machen wir jetzt. Wir gehen jetzt ins BIOS und schalten das ein. Ach fuck, was
muss ich mit dem BIOS drücken? Entfernen, F10, F12, einfach alles. Ich drücke jetzt
einfach alles in der Hoffnung, wir kommen ins BIOS. Weil ich habe zu viel Lack durch
die Capture-Card, als dass ich es erkennen würde. Ha! Moment Leute, dazu muss ich jetzt erst
mal ein ablassen. Erst mal einfach alle Button gepresst, die es irgendwie gab. Ok, Advanced.
Wo schalten wir CPU-Configuration wahrscheinlich? CPU-Configuration. VTD, da ist es, da ist
es. VTD und Intel Virtualization Technology. Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum gibt es
da zwei Sachen? Ich dachte immer, VTD und Intel Virtualization Technology wäre das
gleiche. Und was passiert, wenn ich Active Course Disable? Ist jetzt meine CPU tot?
Ich probiere es lieber mal nicht aus. Man weiß nie, was passiert. Safe, gut. Ok. Wieso
sollte man VTD und Intel Virtualisierung eigentlich aushaben? Keine Ahnung, Gigabyte ist der Meinung,
man sollte das standardmäßig aushaben. Weil, weiß nicht. Ich kann sie ja mal auf Twitter
fragen, dann bin ich nicht nur bei MSI gebannt. Das könnte ich mir jetzt ja mal, das müsste
man sich eigentlich mal als Aufgabe machen. Schaffe es bei allen Mainboard-Herstellern
auf Twitter gebannt zu sein? Du wurdest bei MSI gebannt? Ja, das habe ich schon 30.000
mal erzählt. Ich glaube, die wussten auch nicht, was sie da genau treiben. Und der Social-Media-Typ
war irgendwie gerade im Rage-Quit-Modus und hat einfach gedacht, der mag der Spaß, der
wird gebannt. Hat er ja auch recht. Aber mal ehrlich, das hat er recht. So, jetzt haben
wir Hardware-Virtualisierung. Da, haben wir an. Start, Konsole. Achtung, Windows, please,
come on, brah. Windows. Could not read from CD. Ach, scheiße. Warum? Ah, das sagt, ich
wollte jetzt Windows 95 installieren. Huge, äh, huge monka, monka, äh, sad, äh. Kein
Windows 95. Okay, Windows XP. Wir nehmen das nächste, beste Windows XP. ISO. Will keine
64-Bit, ich will die oldschool 32-Bit Windows. Jawoll. Das ist um 90 SP3. GIF. Rockslox
habe ich wieder eingeschaltet, Virtualisierung. Da, guck, hier. Äh, da. Ich habe das da ausgeschaltet,
weil wir wahrscheinlich nichts zu tun haben. Yes. Legit download. Software famous. Äh,
ich will da jetzt nicht draufklicken. Wer weiß, was ich mir da downloade. Get my OS.
Ich brauche Windows, brauche Windows. Dr. Windows, Hilfe brauche eine CD. Ich glaube,
das ist mir zu Monkathos-mäßig gerade. So kommen Sie, oggy. Chip, Chip, verrät uns
jetzt, wie es geht. Chip. Chip, ja, Chip, wieder super hilfreich. Ach, warum geht Windows
95 nicht, das ärgert mich, ey. Ich hätte jetzt gerne Windows 95 installiert. Echt gerne
Windows 95 installiert. Bootbare Windows 95 CD. All boot disks klingt ja auch wahnsinnig
vertrauenserweckend, ey. Da lade ich mir nix runter. Äh, sind die nicht mal per Konsole
verbinden vielleicht? Ach ja. Ok, das wird nix. Wir machen uns auf was anderes. Get my
OS. Ist da irgendwas? Download. Klingt, ey, den Scheiß installiere ich mir nicht. Das
installiere ich mir nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Ja, Chip, Windows XP ISO Download,
die haben das bestimmt noch. Ja, Windows XP ist aus Pack 3. Fuck. Ach Mensch, ich wollte
jetzt mal, ich wollte jetzt mal so richtig wieder ein klassisches Windows Ding installieren,
aber nee, geht nicht. RIP, dann machen wir es eben stopp. Yes. Und dann machen wir jetzt
einen... Waswindfuture.de, was ist das hier? Ne, das ist ja Service Pack. Das Service Pack
bringt uns ja nix. Übrigens, Sentinel, du musst deinen Steam Account die Comments einschalten,
damit ich da was reinschreiben kann. Das Chat Overlay ist broken? What? Warum ist das Chat
Overlay broken? Oh, wie sieht das Chat Overlay ok aus? Echt jetzt? Stimmt, nee, bei mir
ist im Chat Overlay alles drin. Ach so, ja, das könnte sein, dass das aus dem Bild raus
läuft. Ja, ist total beknackt, guck mal. Musste es auch so machen, dann funktioniert
das. Ich hab das irgendwann mal verschoben, weiß ich nicht, da hab ich ja Fivehead. Ok,
also das Windows 95 funktioniert leider nicht, was echt Massive Sucked. Ok, da können wir
bei der Gelegenheit gleich mal ausprobieren, wie man VMs löscht. So, Remove 100. Das finde
ich gut, dass sie so eine Abfrage gemacht haben, dass man den Kram nicht aus Versehen
löschen kann. Windows ME, na, das wird auch nicht funktionieren. Ich komm vorbei. Windows
ME, das beliebteste Windows aller Zeiten, na. Wow. ME voll ISO. Das ist die Bootdisk,
ja. Das probieren wir jetzt noch mal aus. Ey, wenn alle Stricke reißen, haben wir Windows
2000 ISO. Die gibt's wieder nicht legale. Oh nee, jetzt hab ich die VM schon gelöscht.
Aber wir brauchen eh das ISO wieder. Ok, probieren wir mal mit Windows ME. ISO and Bootdisk,
muss ich da jetzt allen Ernstes ne Diskette dran machen, ne Diskette dran, die das Floppy
Image bootet? Kann es nicht von CD booten? Doch Leute, Windows ME konnte schon von CD
booten. Da kann ich mich sogar noch dran erinnern. Windows 95 konnte 100 Pro von CD starten.
Sorry, Windows ME konnte 100 Pro von CD starten. Ich hab das damals sogar noch von CD installiert,
das geht. Huge Download. Also ME probieren wir jetzt noch, wenn das nicht funktioniert,
installieren wir was ordentliches. Hannah Montana Linux, was zum Teufel soll das denn
sein? Geh weg. Ey, geh weg. Es gibt gewisse Sachen, die kommen noch nicht mal bei mir
in die Virtualisierung, der Virtualisierung unter der Virtualisierung rein. Und da gehört
Hannah Montana Linux dazu. Ok, wie ging das mit dem Upload jetzt nochmal? Local, ISO
Images. Upload. Mega Upload. Mega. Den Mist hat man sich irgendwie gemerkt, ne? Den Mist
hat man sich gemerkt. Ich hab mal den geilsten Joke ever gelesen auf Reddit. Internet ist
made for cat videos. Cat 5 or Cat 6. So, das war schon schlecht. ME voll. Bam. Upload.
Auf geht's. Du hast damals deinen Mega Upload Account geschlossen. Sachen gibt's, ich hatte
nie den Mega Upload Account. Ok, Create for M. 100, Resource Pool, Name, Windows, ME, Next,
Local, Image, ME full. Das ist kein Windows, das ist immer noch Windows 2000. Das andere
gibt's ja nicht. Windows, Default, IDE. Ich mach mal hier ein bisschen Gedanken ehrlich
gesagt, aber es wird schon funktionieren. IDE. Jawoll. Type. Naja, bis zum booten muss
er kommen. Network. Finish. Auf geht's. Windows ME. Hier, bless RNG Leute. Hoffentlich funktioniert's
jetzt. Start. Es ist Windows 95. Äh, Windows ME ist es. Ja, fast. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Windows ME ist es. Ja, fast. Äh, wisst ihr was Leute? Ähm, Hardware. Ich mach mal die
Netzwerkkarte ab. Ich bin mir immer noch nicht so ganz sicher, was ich mir da überhaupt
runtergeladen hab. Ich mach mal die Netzwerkkarte ab. Kann man Netzwerkverbindung hier einfach
trennen? Stop. Network device. Äh, ja. Remove. Gibt kein Network für dich Windows ME. Start.
So. So, und jetzt, jetzt machen wir, jetzt machen wir die volle, die volle Windows Experience
machen wir jetzt. Fullscreen. So, Leute. Windows 95. So wie ihr es seit 30 Jahren, na ok, äh,
nicht übertrieben. So wie ihr es seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr gesehen habt. ME. Ja. Komm.
Das hat ein bisschen Unterschied da. Kommt es mir nur so langsam vor oder war das damals
einfach so langsam? Ich mein, das ist ein halbwegs aktueller Low Power Prozessor mit
der SSD dran. Also, der ist, mag langsam sein, aber nicht so langsam. Hey. Nice, nice, nice,
nice, nice, nice. Prepare as Windows ME. Geiler Shit. Enter. Jawoll. Large Disk Support. Oh
fuck. Ich hab ne Platte, die größer als 512 MB ist. Oh, oh, oh. Restart Computer. In
3FA? Ah, wat? Gut vorm CD. Ich weiß, dass 3FA Diskette ist. Egal, dann installieren wir
es halt nur mit 512. Kann ich auch mitleben. F5 im, im. Echt, ich dachte F5 ist irgendwie
ein Betreiber installer oder sowas. Windows ME hatte Dark Mode. Krasser Scheiß. Wir wollten
eigentlich Boxbox testen. Oh. Das hat funktioniert. Das ging direkt weiter. Alter, das ist ja
Resident Sleeper hoch 5. Wir machen in der Zwischenzeit was anderes, während Windows
installiert. Wir installieren mal ne ordentliche VM. Na gut, der formatiert ja auch gerade
eben in 32 GB, ne? Geht ja halbwegs schnell. Ok, ähm, dann starten wir doch mal nen Container
nebenbei. Wie ging das denn hier? Templates. Ah, hier kann man direkt, ok, wir wollen ein
Ubuntu Template. Download. Ach, ich, also ich muss, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ähm,
ich hatte das Webinterface als nicht mehr, also als nicht so gut in Erinnerung, wie es
jetzt ist. Aber ich glaube, das hat sich gar nicht so viel geändert, aber das macht, das
gefällt mir echt ganz gut. Ihr weißt, dass das LXC ist. So, Create Container. Hostname,
Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, 1,2,3,4,5,6, 1,2,3,4,5,6. Template, Storage, Ubuntu, Route Disk, jaja,
8G, CPU, Memory, alles gut, Network, ja ok, du darfst ja auch per DACP was holen, ist
ok. Ist erlaubt. DNS, ähm, Omanet, Confirm, Finish. Jetzt startet der Container. Also
ich muss sagen, das Webinterface, ja ist ja gut. Ich kann es doch nicht mal mehr aussprechen
gerade, ey. Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Omanet, DNS Overrated, ja. Ja, das ist funktioniert. Create, Task
ok steht da. Wenn der Task ok steht, gehen wir mal von aus. Was macht unser Windows?
40% weiß plattformatiert, jawoll. Start Container, das sollte jetzt ultra schnell
gehen. Eats, Root, 1,2,3,4,5,6, zack, nice, Fullscreen, Fullscreen please, Fullscreen,
ja meinetwegen dann halt so. So, ja, UPDATE. Tatsächlich, das ist easy. Also ich mein Container
ist an sich eine easy Geschichte, wenn es einfach nur darum geht ein Image zu starten.
Aber ist schön. Also das Web, oh Steuerung W ist, äh, ja, ups. Steuerung W ist ja natürlich
äh, Tab zu. Da muss ich, da muss ich aufpassen, ja. Ähm, hallo, UPDATE. Oh, jetzt ist er,
jetzt ist er proppen. Das will er nicht mehr. UPDATE, UPDATE. Ich hab jetzt einfach mal
Fenster zugemacht. UPDATE, UPDATE. Also ich muss sagen, das Webinterface ist echt nice.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut. Ich mein, ich brauch's nicht wirklich, aber es hat auf jeden
Fall was. Das Webinterface gefällt mir echt gut. Nice so, richtig nice so. Besser als
ESX. Naja, war weitem nicht so umfangreich, ne. Aber ESX, also Vmware weiß eh nicht so
genau, was die, was die wollen mit ihrem Webinterface. Erst hatten sie, erst hatten sie
diesen, jetzt, erst hatten sie diesen Windows Client. Der war eigentlich ganz okay. Der
Desktop Client. Danach hatten sie so einen abgrundtief hässlichen Flash. Das war übelst
räudisch schlecht. Und jetzt haben sie eine HTML5 Oberfläche, die geht wieder halbwegs.
Also insgesamt von der Bedienung her finde ich das Webinterface hier jetzt gerade, so
wie es ist, von der Handhabung sogar noch deutlich einfacher als die Vmware Oberfläche.
Gibt's da nichts? Es gibt einen Anliegen, Knopf, Start, Stop und Konsole. Und das Schöne
ist, die Konsole funktioniert ohne irgendwelche Plugins oder sonst was. Was macht eigentlich
unser Windows? Windows ist bei 84%. Abinstall. Oh, jetzt hängt's. Ja, klar. ASCII Aquarium.
Nein, das ist nicht dabei. Das ist nicht dabei. It's Batman. Also Container ist schon mal
sehr easy über die Oberfläche. Das finde ich nice. Das gefällt mir. Guck mal, wieviel
CPUs das sieht. Sollte ja eigentlich nur eine. Ich hab hier nur eine eingestellt. Ja. Okay,
Computerverwaltung ist da drüber anscheinend ganz nett. Snapshots. Würden wir Snapshots
jetzt hier vormachen? Take Snapshot. Blub blub blub blub. Übrigens hier so, bestes
Namenschema für Snapshots überhaupt. So, und jetzt haben wir Rm-Rf/. RIP. Achso, stimmt,
man muss ja mittlerweile nennen. No Preserve Route. Also wir machen das System jetzt kaputt.
Deine Partnerbewerbung schon angenommen. Bis jetzt noch nicht. So, System kaputt. RIP.
Cubuntu. Preboot. Not found. Power off. Not found. Alles RIP. Okay, so. Jetzt haben wir
es kaputt. Stopp. Shutdown wird nicht mehr funktionieren. Okay, und jetzt restoren wir
den Snapshot und gucken, ob es wieder funktioniert. Okay, ich glaube, wir haben es so krass kaputt
gemacht. Die VM, der macht jetzt gar nichts mehr. Man kann die noch nicht mal ausschalten
. Warum geht denn das? Das müsste funktionieren. Okay, dann machen wir es an Snapshot. Restore.
Rollback. Yes. Ja, aber ausschalten müsste doch auch so. Ausschalten muss immer funktionieren.
Einfach Prozess killen im Hintergrund. Oh, das mag er nicht. Das ist das. Das ist merkwürdig.
Also wenn man den kompletten Container RIPt, dann geht gar nichts mehr. Dann ist vorbei.
Wie läuft es? Ist Windows ME? Oh, oh. Setup is preparing. Press Enter. Oh, ja, oh, oh,
huge. Jetzt ist schnell. Jetzt ist huge speed angesagt unter Windows. Please wait. Woa.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt wollen sie es wissen. Mein Mauszeiger ist ein bisschen off. Minimal.
Oh, dieser Speed. Massive Speed. Wie lange ich diesen Installer nicht mehr gesehen hab,
nicht, dass ich es wirklich vermisst hätte oder so. Wie oft ich den Crap installiert habe damals.
Das waren ja noch die Zeiten, wo du bei jedem kleinen Rumgezicke von Windows, Windows neu
installiert hast. Ich glaube Windows 95, 98 ME habe ich jetzt ohne Übertreibung 500 Mal,
wenn es reich neu installiert. Also alles zusammen. Und jetzt kommt dieser sagenumwobene
Installer Selbstanpreisung von Microsoft. Das dauert gerade 30 bis 60 Minuten. Das dauert 5
Minuten. Jetzt kommt gleich Windows ME. Ist das beste Windows, das es je gegeben hat. C
Doppelpunkt Windows. 71 Minuten. Das dauert nicht so lange. Das geht jetzt zack.
Ich meine, wir haben einen Rechner, der zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, wo das Betriebssystem
aktuell war, hatte so einen Rechner, worauf das läuft, hatte vielleicht der deutsche
Wetterdienst in Offenbach oder so. Typical. Ja, ja, Typical ist gut. Most common Software
Components. Ja. Bester Computername N2L6K0. Sehr sprechend. Qt. Chat heißt der jetzt.
Die Zeit ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch egal. Jetzt flutscht es. Eben war es noch 71 Minuten,
jetzt sind es 61 Minuten. Ready to begin. Jawoll, Windows, gibs uns. Gibs uns Windows
ME. Sit back and relax. Jawoll, erzähl uns über die Verbesserung von Windows ME. Und
die exciting new features. Leute, ihr wolltet sie wahrscheinlich schon immer wissen. Microsoft
zeigt uns. Das war Bill persönlich noch, der das damals geschrieben hatte. Das ist
noch Proxmox 6. Das ist eine Windows ME install in Proxmox 6. Einfach zum gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Ja, auf neuen Features, zeig her Windows. Wo sind die neuen Features? Ich wills sehen.
Werbung ist gecrasht. Was macht denn unser Ubuntu? Ist das mittlerweile wieder zum Leben
erweckt? Shutdown. Wie cancelt man denn solche Jobs? Stopp. Wir haben den Container komplett
zerstört. Der ist RIP. Wir machen jetzt was. Darf man das vom Container aus machen? Glaub
ich nicht, oder? Was war das? S nach Proxmox. Oh nee. Geh nicht. Echo. Nee, Echo ist nicht
weg, weil Echo ist ein Build-in von Bash. Wie kann ich das Ding jetzt neu starten lassen?
Ich mein, warum geht das Abschießen denn nicht? Was soll das überhaupt? Yes, bam.
Gibs ihm. Ja, jetzt gehts doch. Hat vorher nicht funktioniert. Wahrscheinlich weil der
alte Job noch lief. Okay, also Backup. Nicht Backup, Snapshots. Also okay, nee, wir starten
es jetzt erstmal und werden wahrscheinlich feststellen, es startet nix. Start, no running
back, kaputt. Komplett, komplett im Arsch. Mal gar nix mehr. So, und jetzt machen wir
den Snapshot. Jetzt müsst ihr eigentlich wieder gehen. Snapshot, rollback, yes. Done.
Okay. Und nun? Start. Start, start, start, start. Er startet. Da ist er wieder. Das ging
zu schnell. Nee, ZFS-Snapshots und Containersachen sind saumäßig schnell. Nice. Mich würd ja
mal interessieren, ob der das unter der Haube mit ZFS-Snapshots gemacht hat. Was wars? 1,
2, 7, yes, nee, root. Wow, warum hat er mich jetzt rausgekickt? Weil, Zpool-List, ZFS-Snapshot-List,
nee. Oh, das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht. Wie listet man Snapshots? ZFS-List-Snapshot.
Easy. Oracle und KS. Das ging anders. Ah, ZFS-List-T-Snapshot, genau. Weil. Ja gut, der macht die Container,
der macht das auch über ZFS-Snapshots. Das ist gut. Das ist nice, du. Kann Proxbox auch
während VM online ist, die VM auf ein anderes Storage verschieben. Ich glaube schon, solang
man, also mit Ceph kann's das glaube ich, ich hab's nie gemacht. Ich hab's nie gemacht.
Ich kenn das nur von Sachen, die ich irgendwo gelesen hab und was die selber schreiben.
Ich glaub, mit Ceph geht das ganz gut. Prinzipiell geht das, ja. Prinzipiell kann der quasi
so Hot Life, wie auch immer man das nennen mag, migraten. Oder könnte man Kunden bei
VMWare, wie bei VMWare, einen Hardware-Pool zur Verfügung stellen, die sie selbst verwenden.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man die Paid-Variante hat, dass man dann
ein bisschen mehr Business-Optionen hat. Ich glaube diese Standard-Variante ist eher für
daheim ausgelegt. Ich mein, oh Windows-Installation. Windows just got better. Leute, da hab ich
drauf gewartet. Endlich. Endlich wurde Windows besser. Ähm, moin Max, hab ich was verpasst.
Ist Proxmox 6 so? Äh, ich find das Web-Interface extrem nice. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel sich
getan hat. Es ist schon ewig her, wo ich das letzte Mal angeguckt hab. Ich find das Web-Interface
sehr, sehr easy zu bedienen. Da kannste nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen. Da kannste nicht
allzu viel verkehrt machen. Container anlegen ist super einfach. Einfach ein Template runterladen,
was man haben will als Container und verwenden. Snapshots sind auch einfach. Stimmt, wir können
mal unsere CPU-Auslastung angucken. Genau, eigentlich. Ah, KVM, das ist Windows. Windows
macht einen Kern komplett dicht. Was, warum steht er unten? Stop all VMs and Containers.
Äh, weil, weil er irgendwie Mist anzeigt, keine Ahnung. Windows an sich läuft noch.
MonkaS, ist das Ding gecrasht? Monka, MonkaSmoke? Wie kann das jetzt sein? Nee, das ist nicht
gecrasht. Aber SSH ist abgekackt. Warum? Ist das grad rebooted? Das ist grad rebooted,
oder? Seh ich das richtig? Trip. Unsere schöne Windows Installation. Na gut, das ist jetzt
nicht so überzeugend. Also, crashen sollte das Ding eigentlich nie. Ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass nur VM wirklich das Ding crasht. Das wäre fail. Ist nicht gecrasht. Ja, aber
ich hab's doch nicht ausgeschaltet. Nein, ich hab den Reboot nicht in SSH eingegeben.
Der SSH ist mir ja schon abgeschissen hier. Guck, da. Top war auf und danach Broken Pipe
Disconnect. Da war nix übers... Du hattest beim Login auf den Proxmox wir SSH ein Reboot.
Das glaub ich net. Fake News. Wo? Hier wird sich eingeloggt. Hier wird ZFS Zeug gemacht
und dann wird Hardtop gestartet. Da ist nix mit Reboot. Und hier kackts ab. Vorher. Das
glaub ich nicht. Ich glaub das Ding hat sich grad Rebooted. Ohne erkennbaren Grund. Boot
from CD. Start Windows from CD. Mal gucken was der jetzt macht. Die Dinger waren ja früher
noch nicht ganz so doof und haben manchmal gecheckt, wenn die Installation zwischendrin
abgekackt ist. Also wenn das Ding wirklich verreckt ist, ist in der Historie bestimmt
noch nix mehr von Reboot zu sehen. Ich hab da auch nix Rebooted. Das hätt ich ja eintippen
müssen. Windows im E-Installation führt zu Reboot. Remove Color. Oh der Dark Mode ist
real Leute. Der Dark Mode ist real. Ey Leute ich drück übrigens Enter und es passiert
nix. Windows mach mal. Hat der Problem mit meinem Enter Knopf? Ja gut wenn Proxmox tatsächlich
regulär Rebooted hat, ist die Frage warum hat Proxmox einfach so regulär Rebooted?
Ist Gendes gefahren oder was? Don't fix. Bam. Jawoll.
Ah. Guck mal es geht, es geht. Geht das an der gleichen Stelle weiter wie vorher? Nee
das ist noch mal neu ne. Das ist ne YouTube Public Chills Tab 8 Stunden sonst was Playlist.
Ok ihr wollt jetzt echt wissen warum das Ding Rebooted ist ne. Also da ist Kernlog
sehen wir nix. Was haben wir hier zu bieten? Warlog. Syslog. Nein das ist natürlich auch
der Kram. Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten? Warlog. Haben die vielleicht irgendwo den
Proxmox Kram gespeichert? Pve. Tasks Index. Sieht man im Web Interface hier unten noch
was? Nee. Stopping all. Start all for m. Das ist nach dem Reboot. Kannst du in der
Web Oberfläche sehen wo? Was? Oh. Der macht doch weiter an der Stelle wo er aufgehört
hat. Auf Proxmox links klicken und dann Syslog. Ja das ist das was wir eben auf hatten. Nee
das ist nicht. So Reboot hat 20.02 irgendwo ne. Na ne das ist ja nur seit dem Reboot jetzt.
Oh. Das ist erst seit jetzt drinne. Wir werden es nie erfahren warum es sich Rebooted hat.
Schieben wir es mal auf die Windows ME Installation. Nein. Geh weg. No. Cute Chat. Nein. Nein.
In drive style ist Windows Schuld. Aber das darf eigentlich nicht sein. Ich hab den tatsächlich
Rebooted Clip kommt. Da bin ich aber jetzt echt mal gespannt drauf. Welches Linux nutze
im Hintergrund? Das ist Manjaro mit i3 WM als Desktop. Finish. Da ist Max Rebooted.
Ok das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken. Ich hoffe es ist kein Chebat. Das gucken wir uns
an. Wo ich angeblich Rebooted hab. The fuck? Wo kam das Reboot her?
Wo um alles in der Welt kommt das Reboot her?
Windows ME hat das eingeben. Was? Hä? Das hab ich ja noch nie gesehen. War Reboot in
der Zwischenablage? Können wir mal gucken. Nö. Ich hab keine Ahnung wo das herkommt.
Das gibt ja auch. Das sieht für mich aus als wird das direkt nach dem Login aus irgendwelchen
Gründen automatisch. Was? Wo kommt das Reboot her? Na Pfeil hoch geht ja nicht. Das ist
ja das erste Mal das ich mich da eingeloggt hab. Und in der Historie stand ja auch nichts
drinne. Wenn ich das mit Pfeil hoch auswählen kann hätte es in der Historie stehen müssen
von dem Ereignis wo ich Pfeil hochdrücken konnte. Wo kommt das her? Aber das ist eigentlich
eine gute Ausrede. Wenn ich irgendwo auf der Arbeit mal wieder aus versehen was Reboot
hat. Das Reboot hat sich von alleine eingegeben. Ich glaub das ist überzeugend. Also Chef also
mit dem Reboot das hat sich von alleine eingetippt. Und ich hab jetzt auch einen Beweis Clip dass
das funktioniert. Passiert hier sowas öfters? Mir würde sowas öfters passieren wenn ich
noch Server administrieren würde aber vielleicht darf ich deswegen keine Server mal administrieren
und muss mich jetzt um so komische Sachen wie Git Repos kümmern. Weil ich den zu oft
die Server rebooted hab. Die wollten es mir bloß nicht sagen. Jetzt ergibt das alles
Sinn. Jetzt ergibt das alles Sinn. Ja aber hier richtig. Guck mal er ist schneller als
das letzte Mal. Aber ohne Mist ich hab keinen Plassen Schimmer wo dieses Reboot hergekommen
ist. Das muss ich mal morgen ein paar Leuten zeigen. Ob die sich das irgendwie erklären
können. Ich hab keine Ahnung wo das herkommt. Sind die Bilder von Stream Deck? Ne die Bilder
sind von meinem selbst programmierten Memetool. Guck da ich zeig dir mal wie das aussieht
in der Zeit wo Windows installiert. Einmal hier zu. Ups, Bummi muss man nicht zumachen.
Guck hier da. Localhost 5002. Da hast du so ne Übersicht mit Text to Speech Dingern oder
irgendwelchen anderen Audio Files oder Bildchen. Und den kannst du dann anklicken. Ich hab
die jetzt auf dem zweiten Bildschirm an im Web Interface. Und das klickst du dann auf
dem zweiten Bildschirm oder auf dem Tablet an und dann macht er Overlay. Du kannst das
auch verschieben wenn du willst. So hier. Oder ein bisschen größer und kleiner machen.
Kann sogar GIFs. Sorry nicht GIFs. GIFs. Genau dann kannst du dir alle möglichen Bilder
reinziehen die du willst. Und dann kannst du die halt overlayen. Oder du kannst zum Beispiel
auch sagen. Das ist ne Text to Speech. Hier ne Text to Speech. Web Text to Speech Engine.
Das ist. Ich weiß nicht ob da 5000 IQ für ausreicht überhaupt. Das haben wir teilweise
sogar im Stream programmiert. Allerdings die Version hier gibt es nicht auf Github.
Die ist ziemlich unfertig auch wenn es nicht so aussieht. Ja ich mein man kann hier zwar
drinne suchen und sowas. Aber es ist nicht schön. Wir müssten eigentlich wenn ich mal
wirklich mal so ne Woche Zeit hab. Müssten wir doch mal on Stream das Memetool ordentlich
machen. Mit im Hinblick von Anfang an auf das was es alles können soll. Nämlich Bilder
Text to Speech und Audio Dateien. Weil ich hab das ja am Anfang von Bilder und GIFs umgebaut
zu Text to Speech und Audio Dateien. Was dann hinten und vorne nicht mal funktioniert hat.
Weil Bilder. Nur mal zu erklären. Bilder ist immer synchron. Ich Bild an Bild aus. Audio
Dateien sind ja anders. Ich brauch ein Bild. Und kann jetzt beispielsweise hier Easy und
wenn ich jetzt Easy sagen lasse. Highlight mir das und muss es dann wieder. Also ne. Play
ist das Gelb und macht es dann automatisch wieder aus. Während ein Bild ist. Das hab
ich dann nachhinein so also ran geflanscht ja. Und. Das funktioniert. Das funktioniert
aber nicht schön. Was ist das? Das Frontend ist Vue.js. Wo ist MonkaX? Ich hab kein MonkaX
und halbwegs ordentliche Auflösungen gefunden. Ja sortieren und sowas können wir dann auch
machen ja. Dass man das nach hinzufüge Datum. Der hat hohe Auflösungen hier. HiRez. Paper
please. Was macht denn unser Windows? 7%. Windows just got better. Noch besser als vorher
schon. Wieso sind auf GitHub Releasen und Community ist fixen lassen? Weil bevor ich
was auf GitHub release will ich zumindest die Version nicht da hochladen. Das funktioniert
für jemand anderes außer mich. Es ist auch hässlich vom Ansatz her. Ja der Gajibus ist
leider auf 100 mal 100. Windows ME ist besser als Windows 10. Ist ja. Also Windows 10. Besser
als Vista auf jeden Fall. Aber das beste Windows ist ja eigentlich immer noch kein
Windows wenn man es sich leisten kann. Oder wenn man den Luxus hat. Mach auf Experimental
Branch. Ne ne. Ich lad das erst hoch. Auch wenn ich nicht mehr die Gefahr laufen muss
dass ich da vielleicht irgendwas drin stehen hab was ich drin stehen haben will oder so.
Es gibt ja ne Version. Die allererste Version die noch keine Datenbank drunter hatte sondern
die Bilder vom Filesystem genommen hat. Die gibt es ja auf GitHub. Ist halt sehr rudimentär
und hat die meisten Sachen noch nicht. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagen will ey ich hab
kein Bock mit diesem Overlay aber ich will die Overlays in OBS verwenden hat das ja auch
die Möglichkeit dass man hier sagt. Ups falscher Knopf. Dass man hier auch sagt hier ich will
das im Browser machen. Ihr sehts ne. Man hat da ne Vorschau im Browser. Den Browser Tab
kann man dann auch im OBS hinzufügen. Und ganz wichtig Light Mode Dark Mode. Was macht
unser Windows? 8% das ist ja High Speed. Das ist ja absolut High Speed hier gerade. Ok
dann probieren wir jetzt nochmal was anderes in Proxmox zu machen während Windows installiert.
Wir legen nämlich nochmal ne Ubuntu VM an. Äh kein Desktop. Sauber. LTS. LTS Alternative
Installer. Network Installer. Sehr gut. Gucken wir mal wie schnell das ist. Ne den da will
ich. Immer mal die 19.05. Sauber Install Image. Blablub. Save. Dann uploaden wir das mal.
Bin so ein bisschen verwirrend dass hier irgendwie die VMs neben dem Storage stehen und sowas.
Das sind doch eigentlich zwei komplett unterschiedliche. Ah ok. Ah man kann das umstellen. Kann man
eigentlich einen PC als Haupt PC nehmen und damit zwei PCs virtualisieren? Klar mach ich
doch hier auch. Ich hab Windows laufen und da drin hab ich mein Ubuntu VM. Äh meine
Manjaro VM. Das sind ja nicht zwei Rechner. Das ist Windows und auf dem zweiten Desktop
von Windows ist vor allem der Workstation mit Manjaro. Kannste auch ohne Probleme zwei
VMs machen wenn es da ne RAM her gibt. Warum nicht? Genau dafür ist es ja da. Ubuntu genau
nicht Ubuntu. Obbei ist ja sogar auf Südafrikanisch was spricht man da Afrikans oder so. Heißt
es ja wirklich Ubuntu und nicht Ubuntu wie die coolen Leute das sagen. Obbei da heißt
es wahrscheinlich Ubuntu. Ich kann Afrikanisch nicht nachmachen. Ubuntu. Ne keine Ahnung.
Das heißt glaube ich wirklich Afrikans. Ubuntu hat GIFs im JIT gebated und Tickets im Jira
erstellt. Genau. Um alles besonders geil auszusprechen. In Südafrika spricht man Englisch.
Ich glaube nicht dass Ubuntu ein englisches Wort ist. Das ist garantiert ein Ureinwohner
Wort oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag. Also irgendwas aus der lokalen Sprache da.
Ubuntu. Ubuntu ist die englische Variante. Wie spricht es der Weep Sprachgenerator aus?
Das können wir mal ausprobieren. Hoffentlich funktioniert es überhaupt noch. Ubuntu. Okay
Windows spricht das so aus. Weep spricht das so aus. Ist gecrashed. Der Weep Text
to Speech Service ist kaputt. Das ist unter anderem ein Problem davon wenn man so Voice
Dinge einfach anflanscht. Ubuntu. Ich glaube dass mein Text to Speech Service einfach kaputt
ist. Der japanische Text to Speech Service ist kaputt glaube ich. Ey warum soll ich die
Bugger, die Bug Ausgabe beste. Achso. Probieren wir mal was anderes. Okay wir probieren das
einfach mal mit einem anderen aus der noch funktioniert. Vielleicht ist mein Programm
einfach noch verbackt. Ubuntu. Wo was? Was? Ubuntu. So toll. Ubuntu. Das hört sich ja
mega mega beschissen an. Ubuntu. Woher hast du eigentlich einen Weep Text to Speech?
Ich hab gegoogelt nach der Text to Speech Engine die japanisch kann. Und dann mussten
wir uns auf der japanischen Seite einen Api-Key generieren und so was. Das war ganz abenteuerlich.
Und ich hab eingestellt wir wollen japanische Frauenstimme und besonders glücklich soll
die das aussprechen. Okay und jetzt. Ubuntu. So wie das die coolen Leute aussprechen. Na
fast fast oder. Ubuntu. Ubuntu. Achso. Oh Gott ist das. Ubuntu. Ubuntu U. Warte mal stimmt
das nicht richtig funktioniert. Was? Was? Nein das hat mit dem Original nicht mal all
zu viel zu tun oder. Na fast fast. Aber Ubuntu funktioniert. Kann das den Linux aussprechen?
Achso was passiert eigentlich wenn man es groß schreibt? Schreit die dann? Ubuntu. Nee.
Kann die Linux aussprechen? Linux. Na gar nicht schlecht. Linux. Was macht unsere Windows
Installation? Oh 47 Minuten nur noch. Ja habt ihr eine glorreiche Idee wenn man die ordentlich
Ubuntu aussprechen lassen könnte? Wird schon besser eigentlich. Lass die mal Windows aussprechen
ja das kann sie bestimmt. Fast fast. Windows. Windows. Windows 95. Oh die spricht es auf
herpanisch aus. Dann schreiben wir mal Windose. Windows. Hä? Fast fast. Windows. Oh Mann was
haben die alles einfällt wenn man sich die Windows ME Installation anguckt oder? Windows
oder Microsoft? Okay. 95. Windows 95. Mach mal 7777. Hä? 777777777777
Mach mal 7777
7777777777777777
Oh man, wir belassen sie mal hierbei
Ach so das ist glaube ich gar kein sagt mal heute das war kein japanischer text to speech oder das war ein koreanischer text to speech kann
das sein
den wir damals verwendet haben
Das könnte koreanischer gewesen sein sogar, als ich doch nicht mal ayayaya sagen lasse
Fast ey fast original oder
Ayaya, ey ey ey ey
Proxmox
Ey das ist gar nicht schlecht
Das geht doch eigentlich das ist definitiv gut
Proxmox
Versuchsfall mit Knulinox
Ja ja nicht schlecht
Nicht schlecht
Ist euch eigentlich mein geniales cashing aufgefallen
Man muss das nur einmal zum webserver schicken und der speichert sich die antwort
euch fällt das schon auf oder wenn ich jetzt klicke
Geht das schnell und wenn ich es ändere dann braucht es einmal lang einmal lang und danach geht schnell
Das ist
Big brain cashing
Lasst sie eher eher aussprechen na gut das ist halt das
Das war klar
Viel Zweier man, nee das funktioniert nicht, was machen so Windows Installationen, ob das
auch fertig wird heute, ich hab so meine Zweifel, ne?
Wie soll ich zu meinem eigenen Reboot von vor zwei Stunden reacten oder was?
Was ist das für ein bescheuertes Reaction Video?
Kann ich zu meinem eigenen Reboot reacten?
Stimmt, mein Ubuntu, Ubuntu ISO ist fertig, wir können jetzt wieder was Sinnvolles machen.
Upload, Upload würde ich bestimmt Apoloda oder so sagen, Apoloda, wollen wir, doch
oder was meint ihr was sie sagt, ich sag sie sagt Apolo, Apoloda, Apolodo, Apolodo sagt
sie, Upload, Ubuntu Server, zack, YouTube man, ich weiß nicht ob mein Reboot so lustig
war vorhin, ich mein, es war ein stinknormaler Blue Screen und Rechner abgekackt.
Ok, Create4M, OS, Linux, was ist, 2.6, achso 5.8 bis 2.6, ISO, Ubuntu, bla bla, next, next,
next, next, next, next, finish, mal gucke, wie das funktioniert, das Video muss 10 Minuten
2 Sekunden lang sein, warum, um extra Werbung zu schalten, ich beherrsche das YouTube Game
nicht mal so richtig, ok, Windows ME Installation gone wrong, Windows ME Installation, du glaubst
nicht was als nächstes geschieht, Windows Nutzer hassen diesen Trick, Language, Englisch,
Na, da müssen wir, da stellen wir wegen der Zeitzone, stellen wir mal Deutschland ein,
wir kommen jetzt ordentlich, Keyboard, yes, Y, yes, no, wir sind nicht French, no, Deadkey,
Top 10 Reboot Fails, ich sehe ihr könnt das deutlich besser als ich solche Clickbait Thumbnails
generieren.
Wir können ja machen irgendwie Katja Grasser Witze, installiert Windows ME, gone wrong,
gone wrong, gone wrong, gone wrong, no, no, no, no, no, no, let's somebody brain go wrong,
Also ich hab auf der Arme einen 4K Monitor, da ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Äh, Hostname, Q-Chat ist schon belegt, was machen wir jetzt?
Aja ja, Fullname, Test, Test, Passwort 123456, bestes Passwort überhaupt, yes, weak Passwort,
weak Passwort ist nicht weak, das ist neues Meta, haben die Geräte auf der Arbeit auch
solche Hostname?
Ne, das heißt ganz seriös, wie heißt mein, mein eines Notebook könnte tatsächlich noch
der Master Chief oder so heißen, das hab ich irgendwann mit dem Felix eingeladen, ich glaube
ne, das war schon ewig her, ne ich glaube das heißt nicht noch so, ne ich glaube das
heißt einfach Vorname, Nachname, Desktop oder sowas.
Ansonsten, auf der Arbeit, die eigentlichen Server, die haben bei uns ganz merkwürdige
Hostnamen, die Hostnamen sind bei uns so kompliziert, dass wenn es kaputt geht, keiner weiß worauf
er sich einloggen muss, überspitzt gesagt jetzt, aber es hat sich jemand gedacht, das
muss so sein und dann ist das meinetwegen auch so, da kann ich ja auch nichts dafür,
wenn ich die Kiste nicht finde, die kaputt ist, aber ich darf eh keine selber administrieren.
Ne, Clocks HD, es ist eher so, dass die Hostnames an sich, die sind noch ganz ok, aber die Domains
sind dann ganz furchtbar wirr, ja so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen wie das was der Patrick gepostet
hat, nur bei weitem nicht so aussagekräftig, ich mein bei SAV DNS EU FA kann man sich
ja immerhin auch vorstellen, das ist ein Server, ein DNS in Europa in Frankfurt und 2004 19
könnte Teil von der IPv6 Adresse sein oder sowas und Punkt.de, da kann man sich ja irgendwie
noch was drunter vorstellen, ne, ne, unsere DNS Namen, ich kann jetzt kein Beispiel sagen,
weil sonst muss ich die DNS Namen verraten, aber die sind so, dass man nicht direkt erkennt,
was was ist und das ist lustigerweise absichtlich so. Man erkennt noch mit Ach und Krach wozu
es gehört, also zu welchem Teilsystem das gehört, man erkennt allerdings das wichtigste
nicht auf den ersten Blick, nämlich ob es ein Produktivsystem ist oder nicht. Also wenn
bei uns Bloop Bloop Bloop System Punkt Bloop Domain Punkt irgendwas Punkt sonst was ausfällt,
hast du keine Ahnung, ist das jetzt ein wichtiges System gewesen, was produktiv läuft oder
ist das jetzt einfach nur eins gewesen, was für Testzwecke da ist. Das weißt du nicht
so direkt, das weißt du mittlerweile, weil man weil man sich merken kann, welche Nummer
ungefähr was ist. Oh, hab ich jetzt gerade ein DNS Server da drauf installiert. Huge.
Brain wieder. Das klingt nicht nach einem Vorteil, der finde ich auch nicht, dass es
nach einem Vorteil klingt. Es ist auch kein Vorteil. Ich finde es eigentlich auch sehr
sinnbefreit, seine Domains so zu nennen, dass keiner durchblickt. Aber wenn sich das die
grasen Oberarchitekten ausgedacht haben, dann soll es so sein, dann dauert es halt auch
mal länger, wenn was kaputt geht. Wenn man das sagt, sind sie alle immer ganz furchtbar
und eigentlich nicht alle, aber teilweise sind sie dann alle total überrascht. Wir hatten
letzten so eine komische Aktion auf der Arbeit, da konntest du quasi nicht wirklich Verbesserungsvorschläge,
doch so ungefähr, so ein bisschen wie, stell es sich wie eine Runde vor, wo man Verbesserungsvorschläge
bringen kann. Du sagst ja, wie wäre es denn, wenn man die Domains wieder so nennt, dass
man wüsste, worauf man sich einloggt, kam der erste gleich an. Nein, das geht technisch
nicht. Ok, warum nicht? Ja, weil mir das jemand so gesagt hat. Ich habe mir gedacht, krasse,
geiles Argument. Ja, und zumindest auf dieser ganzen Verbesserungsvorschlagerunde, das ging
über ein paar Wochen, habe ich dann halt auch mal erzählt, ja gut, es kann durchaus sein,
wenn das was kaputt geht und du nicht weißt, wozu es gehört richtig und du nicht genau
weißt, wie wichtig das System ist, dass du dann halt mal, wenn wirklich was kaputt ist,
dass es dann 20-30 Minuten länger dauert, bis du es wieder am Laufen hast, weil du einfach
20-30 Minuten gesucht hast, auch wenn das Problem nichts Großartiges ist. Da waren
sie alle ganz furchtbar überrascht. Was? Ernst? Ist das wirklich so? Ach ja, da wären
wir ja nie drauf gekommen. Tja, big brain, ja. Da kann man ja auch überhaupt nicht drauf
kommen. Da kann man auch überhaupt nicht drauf kommen, dass es länger dauert, wenn
was kaputt ist, weil man dieses Thema nicht mal findet. Das ist komplett, komplett abwegig
eigentlich, ja. Aber jeder, der mal in einer bisschen größeren Firma gearbeitet hat,
wird das kennen, dass es sehr fragwürdige Designentscheidungen und sowas gibt und das
einfachste, was man da machen kann, ist, es sich einfach am Arsch vorbeigehen lassen,
weil großartig diskutieren bringt meistens nichts, weil keiner überhaupt Bock hat, was
zu machen. Die wollen ja, will ja keiner was wirklich machen, ja. Sobald es darum geht,
dass man selbst was machen müsste, will ja keiner mehr. Und dann sag mal einfach, was
man für Bedenken hat und dann kann es einfach am Arsch vorbeigehen. Ja, und wenn es dann
aber so, sag mal so, wenn es dann mal wirklich sowas gibt, wo einer sagt, ja, bringt mal
irgendwelche Vorschläge, da mach ich dann auch mit. Aber ich hab so meine Zweifel, dass
da was rauskommt am Ende. Und das kennt wahrscheinlich auch jeder, der in einer bisschen größeren
Firma arbeitet, dass da ganz gerne mal von Zeit zu Zeit solche Feedback- und Verbesserungsrunden
und Verbesserungsvorschläge, Meetings und Workshops gemacht werden und dass so ziemlich
alle Verbesserungsvorschläge, die da gesammelt werden, quasi direkt danach schon entweder
nicht mehr drüber gesprochen wird oder quasi im Sand verlaufen komplett. Das ist, vermute
ich jetzt mal bei den meisten Läden so. Was macht eigentlich unsere Windows-Installation?
Oh, 44, sag mal, ist das jetzt nicht nur Virtualisierung von einem PC, ist das auch eine Virtualisierung
von einem Pentium 90 oder so? Aber die Ubuntu-Installation geht ziemlich gut, ziemlich zackig.
Max sagt noch, geht viel schneller, ja. Führt das sich am Arsch vorbeigehen lassen nicht
auf Dauer zu unwahrtbar. Oh ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, macht's. Aber was willst du machen, wenn's
keiner ändern will? Du kannst hier nicht sehen, wenn du dir das selbst alles ans Bein bindest,
dann wirst du ja deines Lebens nicht mehr froh. Welches Manjaro ist das genau? Manjaro? Net
Install. Manjaro Net Install mit I3 als Winner-Manager. Das ist allerdings nicht die Manjaro I3 Edition
oder sowas, was es gibt, das ist das minimal Net Install. Und dann selbst eingerichtet
alles. Du kannst mal im Archiv gucken, wublords.tv, kannst mal im Archiv gucken, da gibt's
einen Stream, da haben wir das eingerichtet. Zumindest so grob. Mit Leiste und Desktop
und so. Kannste drüber scrollen, wenn's dich interessiert. Ja, nice, funktioniert. Und
die VM, die fühlt sich auch wirklich sehr, wie sagt man da heutzutage, snappy an. Gibt's
nix zu meckern. Und das alles auf einem Dual-Core, auf einem Dual-Core Pentium Silber. Also quasi
auf einem bisschen besseren Atom. Kann man sich da echt nicht beschweren. Hat dein aktueller
Job Zukunftsperspektiven, was man jetzt lernen würde. Also wenn du das meinst, was ich Ausbildung
gelernt hab, das war Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration. Und ja, das hat immer noch Zukunft. Also wenn
das keine Zukunft hat, dann hat nix Zukunft. Klar, das ist Zukunft. Die Sache ist bloß
die, rein von Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration von der Ausbildung an sich kannst du dir auch
nicht großartig kaufen. Musst halt schon gucken, dass du irgendwie auch was Spezielles kannst
irgendwie oder zumindest überhaupt was kannst. Wir hatten ja schon so Special Azubis, die
im dritten Jahr irgendwann festgestellt haben, sie können halt nix. Aber ansonsten ist am
besten, du suchst dir halt ein Thema raus, was dich interessiert. Aber was aktuell halt
angesagt ist, ist alles mögliche, was mit Container und Cloud zu tun hat, ist super
beliebt. Warum muss ich jetzt das Keyboard noch mal konfigurieren? Container und Cloud
ist grad sehr angesagt. Du kannst dich natürlich auch, wenn du die Ausbildung fertig hast,
ein bisschen Erfahrung hast, kannst du dich natürlich auch in Richtung DevOps weiterentwickeln,
in Richtung, was auch so ein bisschen Buzzword mäßig ist und in Richtung bisschen Fullstack,
also sprich, wenn ihr Programmieren noch legt, gibt es eigentlich unbegrenzte Variationen.
Warum ich mich für Manjaro installiert hab, weil der Installer gut ist und ich kein Bock
hatte, Arch von Hand zu installieren. PC lustig, das kann ich so schon auch teilweise
zumindest bestätigen, wenn ich mir angucke, wer bei uns alles die Abschlussprüfung schafft,
mir ist keiner bekannt, bis auf einen aus meiner Klasse, aber für den war das einfach
nix, also wirklich absolut nix. Jeder kann diese Abschlussprüfung schaffen, dementsprechend
sagt es auch überhaupt nix aus, wenn du die Abschlussprüfung geschafft hast. Wir hatten
einen in der Klasse, in der Berufsschule, der hat es geschafft, in der Datenbankarbeit
2 von 100 Punkten zu schreiben. Hätte er es einfach abgegeben, hätte er eine 6 gekriegt,
0 von 100 Punkten, aber nein, der hat es versucht, der hat es wirklich versucht und der hat die
2 von 100 Punkten gekriegt, weil er 2x CREATE TABLE geschrieben hat. Das ist 900 IQ+. Versuch
mal fisi im RZ zu werden, dann musst du alles können. Das kann ich teilweise bestätigen,
weil ich war auch fisi im RZ, zumindest relativ viel RZ in meiner Ausbildung, die ist aber
schon ein bisschen her. Hast du viel mit Azubis zu tun? Früher schon mittlerweile kaum noch,
weil wir haben keine mehr, die bei uns in der Abteilung sind. Der letzte ist jetzt fertig
geworden. Hast du manchmal bei Azubis das Gefühl, das wird doch eh nix, selten aber
das kommt vor. War 2 Kandidaten hatte ich das bisher und die haben es beide geschafft,
aber Ahnung hatten sie nicht. Der eine ist jetzt Junior Consultant irgendwo, also wenn
es mit IT nix ist, dann consultet man halt. Ich weiß halt nicht, zu was um alles in der
Welt man ihn hätte konsultieren sollen, aber der ist jetzt Junior Consultant. Und der andere
ist keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Was ist denn dein Job als DevOps? Mach mal Ausrufe
Zeichen Beruf, ich habe das immer mal versucht zu erklären. Bist du auf dem Stable Branch?
Ich bin auf 6.0, 6.0 ist heute rausgekommen. Tja, na colibri. Unfähige Leute hast du halt
überall. War die auf Papier oder am PC die Datenbank? Die war auf Papier. Wie gesagt
meine Ausbildung ist schon ein bisschen her. Das war 2007 und da war ich schon alt für
die Ausbildung. Ich habe vorher noch anderes Zeug getrieben. Hast du in deiner Ausbildung
Windows 99 gearbeitet? Nein, aber wir hatten ganz viel Windows XP. In der Schule und so.
Auf der Arbeit war alles Linux. Mach mal unsere Windows Installationen. Das ist aber
richtig schnell heute. Hey Max hab ein Problem mit meinem PC. Oh jetzt sind wir bei Max Indischer
PC Hotline. Ich habe die Frage verloren. Moment, wo ist es? Hey Max hab ein Problem mit meinem
PC. Ich habe in meinem PC 4GB RAM verboten, das ist aber wenig. Was für meine Zwecke
auch eigentlich reicht, aber irgendwie steht in der Auslassung, dass die Arbeitsspeicher
auslassen die ganze Zeit bei 65% liegt, obwohl ich keine Programme offen habe. Ist das nicht
normal oder? Doch das ist normal. Ungenutzter RAM ist schlechter RAM. Das ist nichts Schlimmes.
Wäre es schlauer ein älteres zu installieren? Nee, Windows 10 kannst du mit 4GB installieren.
Du kannst dir aber einfach noch mehr RAM kaufen, weil das ist aktuell ziemlich billig.
Mit 4GB geht das schon Leute, das funktioniert. Ok, Master Dom, das musst du erst mal hinkriegen.
Ich würde gucken, also ich würde an deiner Stelle gucken, wer war das nochmal? Das Krümelmonster
hat die, ob du nicht noch ein bisschen mehr RAM kaufen kannst. RAM ist aktuell sowas
von billig. Was brauchst du denn für ein RAM in deinem Rechner? Guck mal, der Kram kostet
doch aktuell nichts hier. DDR4, machst du nochmal 4G rein, 28€, 8G, 28€. Da würde
ich gar nicht rumfackeln mit 4GB, da würde ich mir einfach noch 8G mit reinstecken an
dem RAM und Gutes. Ich meine 28€, was willst du da groß verkehrt machen? Da kannst du
noch nicht ne sagen, oder? Sky, wer braucht schon Sky? Ich habe auch für meinen RAM sauviel
bezahlt vor 2 Jahren, oder 3 Jahren, wann habe ich den? 2 Jahren, 2,5 Jahren. Naja,
also wenn du zu wenig RAM für Windows hast, dann wird das auf jeden Fall definitiv deine,
wie sagt man so schön, User Experience verbessern, wenn du einfach mehr RAM rein machst. Und
ich meine, was willst du groß verkehrt machen? Ich meine 25€. Da muss der PC schon richtig
räudig sein, dass es sich nicht lohnt, da mal was neues rein zu stöpseln zusätzlich.
Du musst halt mal gucken, je nachdem, was du für ein RAM drinne hast, dass man mal schaut,
was hast du denn für ein RAM drinne, was brauchst du, was muss noch für ein RAM rein. Ist
es noch DDR3? Dann könnte es ein bisschen teurer werden sogar. Windows Installation,
also die Windows, ich glaube, die will nicht, die ist glaube ich komplett, yep. Da geht
nix mehr. Nee, schon DDR4. Was brauchst du für einen? Tut es dir ganz billig oder brauchst
du ein bisschen schnellerer? Ich würde mal gucken, was ich für einen RAM drinne habe,
dass ich RAM nehme, der vielleicht jetzt ungefähr ähnlich schnell ist, aber ansonsten nehme
einfach das billigste, das funktioniert. Was RAM macht, naja, alles was dein Rechner
irgendwie laden muss, muss der ja irgendwo hin speichern. Also sobald du deinen Rechner
startest, muss der ja irgendwo seine Runtime, also seine Sachen, die er aktuell geladen
hat, irgendwo hin speichern und das macht dein Arbeitsspeicher. Du könntest das theoretisch,
also theoretisch könntest du natürlich auch sagen, man lässt RAM weg und macht alles
auf die Platte. Das Problem ist nur, dass der Zugriff auf eine Platte und selbst auf
eine SSD tausendfach langsamer ist als billigster RAM. Das ist einfach eine Performance-Geschichte.
Du hast im Rechner prinzipiell drei verschiedene Arten von Speicher. Das war ganz grob gesagt.
Du hast drei Arten von Speicher und die sind unterschiedlich schnell und unterschiedlich
teuer. Du hast Speicher direkt in der CPU selbst. Wir fassen jetzt mal alles von Register
bis Level 1, 2, 3, Cache, fassen wir jetzt mal zusammen. Du hast, wie gesagt, du hast
Speicher in der CPU. Der ist extrem schnell, aber teuer. Du hast ganz normalen RAM, so
Riegel hier, die sind deutlich langsamer als das in der CPU, aber immer noch ziemlich
schnell. Du hast sowas wie SSDs oder auch Magnetfestplatten, die sind ziemlich groß,
billig, aber lahm im Vergleich zur Arbeitsspeicher und noch viel, viel langsamer im Vergleich
zur Speicher, die du in der CPU hast. So ungefähr. Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, aber in der
Regel kannst du sagen, in der CPU hast du wenig Speicher und der ist sau schnell und
teuer. RAM ist ein bisschen größer, immer noch ziemlich teuer und auch ordentlich schnell
und danach hast du halt SSDs und Festplatten, die wir jetzt mal alle in einen Topf schmeißen,
die sind halt billig, groß und nicht so schnell. Und wenn du einfach alles auf der Platte speichern
würdest, dann könntest du den Rechner schlicht und ergreifend nicht ordentlich benutzen,
weil der Speicher zu langsam ist. Wenn du anstatt deinem RAM Riegel dort eine SSD reinstecken
würdest, dann wäre dein Rechner unbedienbar langsam. Das ist der Grund warum es diese
Sorte RAM Riegel gibt. Die halt einfach darauf ausgelegt sind, dass du da schnell Sachen reinschreiben
kannst und Sachen verlesen kannst. Dann ist der Rechner kaputt, weil es sich passt, ja
man hat das davon abgesehen. Wenn dein RAM ausgeht und dein Rechner muss anfangen Sachen
aus dem RAM auf die Festplatte zu schreiben, merkst du sofort. Spätestens wenn du das
Programm aufmachst, was du im Hintergrund hattest, was er ausgelagert hat, dann ruckelt
es sich erstmal ein ab. Also du darfst dir das nicht so vorstellen, dass dein Rechner
dann einfach nur langsam ist. Dein Rechner ist unbenutzbar langsam, wenn du eine SSD
anstatt einen RAM Riegel verwenden würdest. Da reden wir von tausenden Unterschied von
der Geschwindigkeit her. Wenn du noch was wissen willst, sag ruhig. Doch jeder Rechner
hatte RAM, garantiert. Online-Ritter, jeder Rechner vor dem du mal gesessen hast, hat
das Rad RAM. Und wie viel Speicher hat so ein gängiger Prozessor, der Cache ist doch
was anderes. Ich hab das jetzt alles mal in einen Topf geschmissen. Du hast eigentlich
hast du in der CPU auch noch drei verschiedene Speichertypen. Du hast einen... vielleicht
war es ein Joke, vielleicht war es auch Debate, vielleicht war es auch... vielleicht wollt
man das auch wirklich wissen. Keine Ahnung, das erkennt man im Chat ja schlecht. Also normalerweise
hast du auch in der CPU drei verschiedene Speichersorten. Du hast da eine Register,
die sind halt kurz klein, aber saumäßig schnell. Register sind das womit ein Prozessor quasi
seine Daten hält, mit denen er gerade rechnet. Wenn du bei einem Prozessor sagst, ich möchte
zwei Zahlen zusammenzählen, dann muss das erstmal aus dem RAM geladen werden. Dann kommt
das in den Register rein und auf dieses Register wird dann eben der Befehl zum Addieren von
Zahlen angewendet. Ich glaub so kann man das ganz gut umschreiben. Und der Output landet
dann wieder in einem Register. Da kann ich mir entscheiden was ich damit mache. Zum Beispiel
zurück in RAM schreiben. So und dann hast du natürlich, dass die ganze Sache noch ein
bisschen beschleunigt wird, hast du noch Layer 1 und Layer 2 Cache in deiner CPU. Der ist
in der Regel dafür da, dass du eben nicht jedes mal die Sachen, die du in dem Register
brauchst, um halt, dass deine CPU ihre Arbeit machen kann, dass du die eben nicht jedes
mal aus dem RAM laden musst. Und mittlerweile sind die Sachen natürlich auch so clever
und können Sachen wunderbar im Voraus laden. Also die versuchen ja schon die Daten schon
bevor die eigentliche Rechenoperation passiert in der CPU, dass die Daten schon mal zumindest
im Cache drinnen sind. Dann geht das natürlich viel schneller als aus dem RAM laden. Ich
weiß, ehrlich gesagt hab ich keine Ahnung wie groß aktuell Layer 1 und Layer 2 Caches
sind. Wahrscheinlich paar MB oder so, wahrscheinlich irgendwie. Müssen wir mal gucken was hat
denn so ein Ryzen für Layer, für den Cache? Gutzen, wo ist er? Ne, äh, doch, oder? Hatt
er so? Cache. Gibt's nicht. 32 MB. Letztendlich macht's aber auch keinen Unterschied. Es betrifft,
betrifft auf alle CPUs mehr oder weniger so zu, was ich erzählt hab. Du hast Register,
du hast Layer 1 und Layer 2 Cache. Kann man die Prozessor Caches eigentlich benchmarken?
Klar. Im Task Manager sieht man das, ok. Hab ich mir noch nie angeguckt. Ist eigentlich
auch meistens relativ unwichtig, dass man das weiß. Oh hier Performance. Ja hier, ne,
doch, oder? Doch kommt hin. Layer 1 Cache 384. Oder ist das was Belegtes? Ne, das ist insgesamt
was ich hab, ne. Ist aber nicht viel. Hätte ich gedacht, das ist ein bisschen mehr. Aber
da sieht man eben, das ist halt auch Speicher, da ist ziemlich kostenintensiv, ja. Übrigens
danke für die ganzen Follows heute wieder. Guck mal rein, wenn wir das so haben. Welche
Leute wir im Q-Chat heute begrüßen dürfen. M-Macky Ritzlayer. Rice Lair? Weiß nicht,
ob ich das richtig ausspreche. Tri-Denis-3-Denisty. I am left adjoined to Pepega. Ganz grandioser
Name. Der Gironimo. Dionix-Deaf. Mr. Marcel 4. Propel-Bloodform. Sneay. Ta-Ace. Benny97-AT.
Und jetzt ganz frisch noch das Beat-Brot, das schon jetzt gerade end-followed und gefollowed
ist, weil den kenn ich schon. Und den Tekko-Nex-VM. Ja, wer mir das ganze hier gefällt und noch
nicht gefollowed hat, der kann natürlich gerne followen. Und ähm, heute machen wir
nicht so viel sell-out. Passt. Wir haben übrigens seit neuestem auch einen Discord-Server. Wollte
ich noch mal anmerken. Auf Twitter und YouTube bin ich auch am Start, aber YouTube ist eher
für Gaming und ich mache in letzter Zeit wenig. Genau, lasst ein Abo da, aktiviert die Glocke.
Die Partnerschaft, ich hoffe, dass die Partnerschaft inbound ist, aber Twitch hat ja schon gesagt,
es kann bis zu zwei Wochen dauern. Und nachdem ihr die letzten Tage zu unglückliche Sachen
angeklippt habt, wo ich mich einmal bei der Seite vertippt habe, wo ich fast auf ner Porno-Seite
rausgekommen wäre. Und einmal, wo wir uns die Job-Beschreibung angeguckt haben, wo ich
mich dazu hinreißen lassen hab, anstatt männlich-weiß-divers, äh, männlich, ah fuck, anstatt männlich-weiblich-divers
aus Spaß zu sagen, männlich-weiß-deutsch. Und es ist ja jemand, bevor ich eigentlich
gesagt hab, nein, was es richtig heißt, noch genau diese vier Sekunden geklippt hat. Und
wenn das die falschen Leute sehen, dann denken die sich wahrscheinlich, da wachs hier krasser,
anti-feministen, sonst was Nazi, und dann kriegt er keine Partnerschaft. Aber ich hoffe
ja mal drauf, dass Twitch sich das Ganze nicht komplett out of context anguckt, ja. Viel
geiler war das DevOps-Angebot, welches sich als Sys-Admin rausgestellt hat. Ja Moment,
das war ja nicht nur Sys-Admin, du solltest ja DevOps machen, Sys-Admin und Projektmanager
in einem. Ach Leute, wollen wir uns die letzte halbe Stunde noch Job-Beschreibung angucken?
Macht mal nen Vorschlag, nach was wollen wir heute suchen? Und was für ein Job-Admin
sind die? Ich hab noch nie verwendet. Google Jobs. Okay, ich find bei Golem sind die lustigsten
Sachen drin, aber die sind halt meistens schlecht. Block-Chain-Engineer, sowas. Ich such da jetzt
mal wirklich danach. Block-Chain. Das ist so verrückt, das könnte tatsächlich Leute
geben, die das suchen. Wie viel DevOps haben wir in der Umgebung? Wo stellt man hier bei
Google überhaupt ein? Achso, das ist Google direkt. Wo findet man Google Jobs? Wo ist
das? Ich hab das noch nie verwendet, ich weiß nicht wo das steht, das müsst ihr mir jetzt
sagen. Hier irgendwo more Jobs. Ich weiß, dass der Clip schon so viele Aufrufe hat.
Stepstone. Da haben wir auch schon ein paar Bewerber gehabt. Wo ist denn Google Jobs?
Google für Jobs. Wo ist der Link dazu? Ja, ich hab das auch vor einer Weile gelesen,
dass es das gibt. Aber ich weiß nicht wo das ist. Heise Jobs hätten wir auch noch
zu bieten. Cobalt-Programmierer-Jobs, ja das hast du das letzte Mal schon gezeigt. Google
Jobs-Search-Engine. Ach hier, Jobs-Google.com. Das ist was anderes. Ach in die Google-Search
ist das eingebaut. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt hier mal suchen nach DevOps-Engineer, dann
ist es in der Google-Search drin. Oder auch nicht. Wir nehmen jetzt mal Heise Jobs. Oder
wir können auch Stepstone, da hatten wir auch schon ein paar Bewerber. Können wir
nehmen. Ok, also was wollen wir heute mal für den Job suchen? Das letzte Mal waren
ja die DevOps-Leute dran. Wollen wir mal nach... Vollstärk, sehr gut. Was mit Jobs
am Ende? Also muss man dann sagen, Jobs oder sowas. Ok, Vollstärk. Vollstärk in Frankfurt.
Das könnte sein, dass es Amerika-Unis. Vollstärk-Developer, männlich, weiblich, divers. Ich muss jetzt
richtig sagen, das gibt es noch 30 Milliarden Clips. Für Baufinanzierung, Vollstärk-Entwickler,
6 offene Systeme. Das ist aber wenig. Haben die noch mehr? Das müssen wir jetzt gerade
mal überprüfen. Da gibt es schon mal jede Menge mehr. Und wie sieht es hier aus? Vollstärk.
Wir haben 12 passende Jobs. Ok, ok, da kann man es jetzt auslassen. Also was haben wir
heute zu bieten? Ohje, ohje, es geht schon gut los. Mal in Berlin? Frankfurt. Freiburg,
Berlin, Hamburg? Homeoffice. Da gucken wir mal. PHP-Entwickler. PHP-Fullstack-Entwickler.
Na, das ist doch was, hä? Das ist aber Homeoffice. Homeoffice ist POG. Homeoffice ist POG. Also
was haben wir hier zu bieten? PHP-Fullstack-Entwickler. Waschbär und Minibär. Ich habe noch nie was
von gehört. Bla, bla, bla, bla. Green GmbH. Bla, bla, bla, bla. Gemeinsam lebendig wirtschaften.
Bla, bla, das ist alles uninteressant. Bla, bla, bla, bla. Ok. Deine neuen Aufgaben. Entwickle
es gemeinsam im Team. Online-Shops auf Basis PHP-Framework. Habe ich noch nie im Leben
gesehen. Partnerunternehmen. Du prüfst einfach und gibst Aufwandschätzung und Features ab.
Das ist auch für den Entwickler vollkommen normal. Du führst Code-Reviews durch. Das
ist für den Entwickler auch ok. Du behältst neue Trends im Blick. Das ist auch vollkommen
ok. Du bringst mit. Du hast ein abgeschlossenes Studium. Bla, bla, bla. Ausbildung. Ok,
das ist auch normal. Du hast mindestens 3 Jahre Erfahrung im Bereich PHP. Ok, das wäre
für mich schonmal nix. Du arbeitest selbstständig konzentriert, legst hohen Wert aufs Daumen.
Das ist alles ok. Da kann ich nicht mal drüber flamen. Idealerweise bringst du bereits Erfahrungen
mit vollen Technologien und Tools mit. YI-Framework noch nie gehört. PHP, GitLab, Docker, HTML
CSS, JavaScript, SQL, Maria, Hira. Sorry, sorry. Ich hab's richtig ausgesprochen. Ich
muss korrigieren. Jira, Slack und Basiskenntnisse in Linux. Vollkommen in Ordnung. Wahrscheinlich
weil sie da Basiskenntnisse in Linux hingeschrieben haben, ist es da voll stack. Ok, das erwarte
dich. Wir heißen dich in unserer Web-Level. Interesse geweckt. Ehrlich gesagt finde ich
die Stellenanzeige ziemlich langweilig. Es ist, da ist kein Blödsinn drinne wie das
letzte Mal. Ähm, ja Patrick ist es für mich auch null voll stack. Ähm, es ist einfach
ziemlich null nach 15. Also sie würde mich jetzt nicht großartig ansprechen und wahrscheinlich
die meisten Leute die zu trifft auch nicht. Also so, null nach 15 irgendwie. Ok weiter,
der nächste voll stack. Oh, oh, Abmahnung ist raus. Abmahnung ist raus. Male, Female.
Abmahnung ist raus. Sofort. Oh, das ist er noch auf Englisch. Das gibt direkt, das gibt
direkt Klage. Ja. Technischer Support after go live. Das heißt im Endeffekt so viel wie
wir haben irgendwas unfertiges als live deklariert und jetzt musst du dich um den Mist kümmern.
Ähm, Angular 6. Ich habe keine Ahnung von. JavaScript, CSS. Das ist irgendwie langweilig
so die bekannten. AP Development in Java Spring Boot und App Development. Du machst ja alles.
App Anwendung, JavaScript, CSS, Angular. Java Spring Boot was Backend ist. Das ist eigentlich
Backend Geschichte Spring Boot. Ähm, und dann noch App Development. Das ist, da kann
man ja wirklich voll stack zu sagen, wobei das eigentlich mit voll stack in dem Fall
nichts so großartig zu tun hat. Egal, aber das ist ganz schön wild zusammengewürfelt.
You are not afraid to work outside of your comfort zone. Das klingt irgendwie schonmal
ein bisschen merkwürdig. You like to talk English. Nein. Ich kann mich verständigen
auf Englisch, aber ich hab keinen großen Bock den ganzen Tag über Englisch zu labern.
Okay, spricht mich absolut null an. Also würde mich, wenn ich das suchen würde, absolut
null ansprechen. Da steht noch nichtmal was, was die irgendwie, warum man überhaupt zu
ihnen sollte. Schau mal bei Zipgate. Wieso haben die auch Jobangebote? Zipgate, das ist
doch, das ist ein Voip-Anbieter, oder? Jobs, Zipgate Jobs, okay. Wenn du meinst, wir sollen
da mal gucken, dann gucken wir da mal. Äh, 11 offene Stellen. Was haben wir da so zu bieten?
Fullstack, ah, das sind auch Fullstack Leute. Ein Koch sogar, die wollte es wissen. UI-Designer,
Software-Engineer, Web-Entwickler. Okay, dann gucken wir uns mal den Fullstack hier an.
Deine Arbeit möchtest du nicht nur über den Town geworfen bekommen und stattdessen ein
neues Feature von der Konzeption bis zum Release und darüber hinaus bekleiden. Java
und JavaScript sind keine, auch noch in Kombination. Muss das sein? Ich hab ja schon keinen Bock
auf JavaScript, aber muss es dann auch noch Java sein? Und gehen dir fluffig von der Hand.
Du kannst problemlos an einem Tag tief in CS und am nächsten Tag in MySQL einsteigen,
mit deinem Teamleaf zu übernehmen und bist begeistert, wenn Kunden deine Arbeit sofort
nutzen. Dein Wissen gibst du keine Ahnung. Okay. Unser Technologie-Stack, JavaScript.
Modernes JavaScript. Node.js, React, Redux. Redux war diese Router-Geschichte für React,
ne. Yarn ist das, was die coolen Leute als NPM-Ersatz verwenden. Weil NPM verwendet,
wenn man cool ist, verwendet man heutzutage kein NPM mehr. Ähm, ja und natürlich Spar,
ja Single-Page-Application muss sein. 2019. Unsere Backends sind auf Wild, Fly, Swarm
und Vertix-basierten Java-Micro-Surfaces. Weiß nicht, was es ist. Ich hab beide Sachen
aber schon nie gehört. Ähm, aber gut, ich mein letztendlich, das ist ja die Stellenanzeige
von denen, die können natürlich suchen, wen sie wollen. Das muss ja nicht, ne. Nur weil
ich, weil es mir nix sagt, heißt es nicht, dass es Blödsinn ist. Ähm, die wir per Rest
und Enterprise-Message-Bus verfügbar machen. Außerdem haben wir noch mehrere Perl- und
Java-SE-Systeme im Einsatz. Krass. Perl. Zusätzlich integrieren wir Zipgate in andere
Produkte und nutzen dazu die Apis der Anbieter Google-Saleforce. Ja, Salesforce. Da. Business
halt. Wir stehen auf Clean-Code und haben einen einheitlichen Code-Style. Ich find das cool,
dass sie das in die, dass sie das in die, dass sie das in die Stellenanzeige reinschreiben.
Weil wir haben zum Beispiel keinen einheitlichen Code-Style. Bei uns heißen sogar, jetzt muss
man sich mal vorstellen, ne. Bei uns heißen sogar manche Namen, ähm, auf Deutsch. Wir
haben dann so Java-Klassen wie, ähm, ich denk mir jetzt mal was aus, äh, neuer Vertragspartner
erstellen. Heißt dann bei uns so ne Java-Klasse oder sowas. Eine hohe Code-Qualität ist uns
extrem wichtig. Wir entwickeln daher Testgetriebe und unternehmen unsere Testcode genauso ernst
wie unser Produktivsystem. Ich find das gut, dass sie das reinschreiben. Wir haben ein
zentrales Continuous Delivery System mit Netz und doppelten Boden, wo wir einfach täglich
neue Software und unsere Kunden ausrollen. Ja. Was solltest du mitbringen? Spaß an neuen
Technologien. Du kannst mit unseren bestehenden Technologiestack arbeiten. Du bringst erste
DevOps-Skills mit. Das ist wahrscheinlich das Einzige, was ich für diese ganze Anzeige
mitbringen würde. Also bei gut Java Script CSS krieg ich auch auf die Reihe ein bisschen,
ein bisschen, äh, SQL ist auch kein Ding. Allerdings bin ich bei weitem nicht der Profi
Frontend-Entwickler und auch Java Microservice ist nicht so mein Ding, wo ich mich aktuell
gut auskenn. Aber ich mein, muss ja nicht unbedingt für mich was sein, ne. Du übernimmst
zu 1.3.10 deine Komfortzone, machst du dir das nicht allzu bequem. Agile Software-Entwicklungsmittel,
die Anzeige ist okay. Ich find die eigentlich ganz gut gemacht. Das erwartet dich, flache
Hierarchien. Das schreiben sau viele, ne. Ähm, Spaß, kein Überstrich. Das finde ich
auch schon mal gut, dass sie das hinschreiben. Weil wir haben es letztens gelesen, bei allen
anderen Anzeigen, bei fast allen Anzeigen stand überall drinnen, ähm, so nach dem
Motto, flexible Arbeitszeiten, mhm. Und der eine war sogar so und hat geschrieben so nach
dem Motto, ja man kriegt die Überstunden auch bezahlt. Also ich mein jetzt ja, wie?
Steht das überhaupt zur Diskussion, dass man Überstunden bezahlt kriegt? Was auch immer.
Äh, was ist der Unterschied zwischen koden und programmieren? Pff, nix. Koden könnte
man sagen, ist der reine Akt des Eintippens von Sourcecode in den Editor oder in die Idee
und programmieren, auch noch das Gedanken machen, was man für einen Code schreiben
soll. Aber im Prinzip ist das, äh, kein Unterschied. Ein Pater, der höflich zu, das finde ich
cool sowas. Das, ich finde das fehlt wirklich bei vielen. Das fehlt bei uns auch so ein
bisschen. Ähm, dass man einfach jemand am Start hat, der einem zeigt, wie der Laden
gerne hätte, dass Dinge gemacht werden. Und was ist dann Hexhorn? Äh, mit dem Hoodie
vorm Rechner sitzen und, äh, Terminal grün, grüne Schrift haben. Kein Tracecode. Also
ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, also das, was die hier schreiben, finde ich recht ansprechend,
ja. Dass sie auch gleich sagen, dass hier nach dem Motto, musst du hier im Anzug kommen.
Frühstück, Mittagessen auf Haus ist auch sehr nice. Und Kinderbetreuung in den Ferien
ist auch gut. Also ich muss sagen, die finde ich gut. Ich mein, trifft jetzt auf mich persönlich
nicht wirklich gut zu, was es hier geht. Aber ich finde, das hat was. Also das ist nicht
schlecht. Also wenn, wenn, da würde ich echt drüber nachdenken, mich dazu bewerben, wenn
halt das, was die haben wollen, ne, also wenn ich zum Beispiel gewusst hätte, was Wildfly
Swarm Vertex basierte Java Microservices sind, dann, ja, aber ansonsten, ich hab auch von
Java keine große Ahnung. Aber das finde ich gut hier. Also wer hat das geschrieben? Steinex
hat das geschrieben. Also falls du was zu tun hast mit hiermit und, oder du auch am Erstellen
der Anzeige beteiligt warst, ich finde, das ist wirklich gut geschrieben und auch die
Vorzüge ist eigentlich genau das, was Leute, denke ich mal, sich wünschen. Ich meine,
für mich wird es zutreffen. Kinderbetreuung ist mir jetzt egal, aber wer weiß, wie es
mal ein paar Jahre aussieht. Das ist zumindest mal eine Anzeige, wo man sieht, dass nicht
einfach die Personalabteilung irgendwas sinnlos hingeschrieben hat, sondern dass da auch
die Leute dabei waren, die was damit zu tun haben. Ja, Personalabteilung ist oftmals ein
hoher Frauenanteil. Grillkonfirm, da der Chat wieder, ey. Also bauen sich die Personalabteilung
auch 80% Mädels. Max hat mir noch schon mal besprochen, für Kinder brauchst du eine
Frau. Nachdem ich Menschen an sich nicht mag, mag ich natürlich auch, und vor allem Kinder
nicht mag, muss ich mir das eh ganz genau überlegen. Willst du vielleicht mal die Fragen
noch durchgehen? Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Ja, da ist Schönstein. Ich finde,
ich finde es gut gemacht. Ich brauche noch mal eine Stellanzeige, wo ich auch was zu
sagen kann. DevOps. Oh, ich muss mal gucken. Irgendwas, was, was, was, was kann, ich kann
nichts zu Fullstack-Java-Developern, Fullstack-Java-Geschichten sagen. Also, was haben wir hier so zu bieten?
IT-Konsulten, DevOps, was ist das für eine Mischung? Scala-Java-DevOps, Solution-Architekt,
was es alles gibt, ey. Experte DevOps, das ist, das ist für mich hier. Das ist für
mich hier, Experte DevOps. Wie gesagt, ich habe schon DevOps gemacht, da hieß es nicht
mal DevOps. So, was wollen die? Experte, DevOps-Experte. Flow 96, ich weiß, ich fahre auch öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel, deswegen, ich meine das schon ernst, wenn ich sage, ich mag keine Kinder,
vor allem mag ich keine Kinder im Zug. DevOps-Engineer Agile bei der Telekom, wo, wo waren die? Hier,
DevOps-Engineer Agile, das müssen wir auch noch schnell gucken. Ich will jetzt erstmal
die hier gucken, DevOps-Experte, das ist hier, das war es für mich. Also, blablabla, blablabla,
blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla. Was erwarte dich als Spezialist für das
Managen von IT-Systemen? Stellst du in unseren DevOps-Teams einen reibungslosen Betrieb der
IT-Infrastruktur und Cloud-Systeme unserer Kunden sicher? Das ist nicht unbedingt das,
was man sich unter DevOps forscht. Ja, aber kann trotzdem sein. Für Kunden entwickelst
du DevOps und Automatisierungskonzept. Ja, das hat damit was zu tun und treibst zusammen
mit deinen Kollegen Ideen zu, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla. Automatisierung
ist okay. Erstelle DevOps und Automatisierung. Die erwähnen hier so oft das Wort DevOps ohne
irgendwie genauer zu spezifizieren, was sie da jetzt konkret darunter meinen. Ich meine,
was soll denn ein DevOps-Konzept sein? Das muss ja in was Bestehendes passen. Installiere,
konfiguriere und administriere unsere Systemlandschaft. Das ist auch nur zum Teil DevOps. Ich meine,
das gehört dabei. Setze Systemarchitekturen gemäß Kunden-Sicherheitsanforderungen in
Zusammenarbeit mit Systemen. Okay, ja, passt. Optimiere bestehende Infrastruktur hinsichtlich
der DevOps-Automatisierungsansätze. Okay, die verraten uns nicht, was sie sich genau
eigentlich wünschen. Sind die 24 oder 25-Fränker-Faces-Set-Emoves schon belegt? Nee, bloß 5-Hertz.
Genau, DevOps-Experte heißt du bist pro, definier es selbst. Das kann ja nur schief gehen.
Zumindest mal so grob, was sie sich vorstellen, muss ja einem schon mal erzählt werden. Sonst
ist das so ins Blaue hinein. Was erwarten wir von dir? So wie Leidenschaft zu Cloud-Themen,
Erfahrung im Aufbaubetrieb hoch, verfügbare Web-Applikation und Cloud-Lösung, gute Kenntnis
im Umgang mit Tools Jenkins, Maven Java, Ansible Terraform Docker, also bis auf Maven, ja,
Vergeisterung für System-Automatisation und DevOps-Prinzipien, ja, analytisches Denken,
konzeptionelle Stärke, hohes Qualitätsbewusstsein sowie ausgeprägtes Service-Orientierung.
Reisebereitschaft? Nö. Prodamos Kurs, genau. Warum xxSATA nutze den Gestaltungstransfer
von xxSATA? Entwickle dich durch kontinuierliche Trainingskonferenz-Teilnahmen. Profitiere
von flexiblen Arbeitszeiten für gute Leute. Nein, in der Regel profitiert kaum jemand
von flexiblen Arbeitszeiten. Du profitierst davon, wenn du die Arbeitszeiten hast, die
in deinem Arbeitsvertrag drinstehen. Davon profitiert auch deine Work-Life-Balance. Genieße
einen professionellen Anfall. Die Anzeige ist crap. Ok, was will die Telekom noch? Doch,
der Unternehmer profitiert, ja, wenn man es so sieht, natürlich. Natürlich kommt es
darauf an, wie flexible Arbeitszeiten definiert sind. Aber ich fand es viel besser, wie das
die anderen gemacht haben, die man uns vorher angeguckt hat, die hingeschrieben haben,
keine Überstunden. Das ist wichtig reinzuschreiben, weil viele gehen da im Kopf schon so aus
so nach dem Motto, ja, die Leute sind natürlich selbstverständlich bereit da Einsatz zu bringen
und haben überhaupt keine Probleme mit Überstunden zu machen. Ich finde den Ansatz an sich schon
mal genau verkehrt rum. Du bist genauso zu dem verpflichtet, was in deinem Arbeitsvertrag
drinsteht. Und wenn in meinem Arbeitsvertrag drinsteht, ich habe keine Ahnung, 30 Stunden,
dann will ich in der Regel auch 30 Stunden haben. Und nicht so nach dem Motto, ah ja,
wir haben gerade wieder ein Projekt kurz vor dem Abkacken, wir müssen das jetzt jede Woche.
Das ist bei uns auch so. Da würde ich allerdings einfach so etwas wie Gleitzeit reinschreiben,
da weiß man nämlich, dass sich das wirklich auf das Kommen und Gehen bezieht. Für mich
kann flexible Arbeitszeiten alles heißen.
Wir haben das in den letzten Jobangeboten gesehen, was sie sich da teilweise darunter
vorstellen mit flexible Arbeitszeiten. So nach dem Motto, Urlaube genehmigen wir immer
schnell. Und dann kamen irgendwie noch drei Sätze hinten dran. So nach dem Motto, unter
welchen Umständen Urlaube nicht schnell genehmigt werden. So gut wie jeder Laden hat eine Kernarbeitszeit.
Du wirst kaum haben, dass du Leute hast, die von 23 Uhr bis 5 Uhr da sind und dann hast
du andere Leute aus dem gleichen Team, die von, keine Ahnung, 11 bis 19 Uhr da sind.
So eine gewisse Kernarbeitszeit hast du in jedem Laden. Komplett, wie du willst, haben
eigentlich die wenigsten. Ich kenne niemanden, der wirklich komplett arbeiten kann, wann
er will. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie das funktionieren soll, wenn du den Leuten nie
über den Weg läufst. Ausnahmen bestätigen, die Regel gibt es bestimmt. Bei uns ist es
zum Beispiel so, wir haben auch nur theoretisch Kernzeiten, aber in der Regel sagen wir,
es sollte sichergestellt sein, dass zwischen 11 und 16 Uhr jemand da ist. Fertig.
Jemand da heißt nicht alle da, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es flexibel genug. Du hast
die Möglichkeit, zwischen 5 Uhr oder 11 Uhr anzufangen oder zwischen 13 Uhr und 21 Uhr
Schluss zu machen. Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung, das ist doch flexibel genug.
Das würde ich ohne Gleichzeit verstehen. Zu welchen Zeiten arbeitest du noch? Normalerweise
mache ich so, dass ich um 5.45 Uhr aufstehe und fange ungefähr um 7 Uhr an und um 15.30
Uhr gehe ich wieder heim. Vier Tage die Woche, nicht drei Tage. So mache ich es normalerweise.
Warum ich so lange brauche, liegt einfach daran, weil ich festgestellt habe, dass ich
so lange vorm Rechner sitze und auch auf der Arbeit so lange vorm Rechner sitze. Deswegen
mache ich es immer so, dass ich morgens und mittags die Strecke zum Bahnhof laufe. Ich
fahre nicht bis zum Bahnhof direkt vor die Tür, sondern ich steige am Südbahnhof aus
und laufe dann nach Frankfurt rein und mittags zurück. Das dauert auch noch mal so, wenn
man langsam ist, eine halbe Stunde. Aber da hat man ein bisschen Bewegung im Vergleich
zu sonst einem ganzen Tag nur rumhocken. Gucken wir das nächste Mal weiter, ich habe keinen
Bock mehr zu gucken. Fragen hatten wir noch welche, aber ganz kurze Zeit. Was haben wir
hier noch flexibel? Wir haben auch so viele Fragen, haben wir gar nicht. Muss ich eigentlich
jemand in der IT noch wirklich bewerben und auf Stellenanzeigen melden? Geht doch eigentlich
alles nur über Headhunter. Na ja, also ich bin zum Beispiel nicht bei Xing angemeldet,
allerdings hatte ich auch schon Leute, die mit mir schon mal zusammen gearbeitet haben,
dass sie mich angerufen haben und gefragt haben, hier willst du nicht. Das kommt auch
vor. Damitus gesehen hat Google Chops habe ich gesehen. Gibt es irgendwie eine Cutscam?
Jetzt können wir uns mal überlegen. Was für Fragen habe ich denn übersehen? So viele
gibt es auch gar nicht. 8 Jahre Swift Erfahrung, ja ist klar. Was macht eigentlich unsere Windows
Installation? Ich glaube das ist RIP. Ich glaube hier installiert nichts mehr. Wieso
kopierst du immer Ausrufzahmen? Hier, gibts eine Erklärung zu. Du kannst jetzt schon die
Streamqualität ändern, ist das nicht Partner Only? Nee, wenn man regelmäßig Zuschauer
bekommt und Kapazitäten frei sind, kriegt man das auch als Twitch-Plep. Was? Das ist
jetzt irgendwie die Chebat-Frage. Die Benchmark-Man, um was ging es denn da? Um irgendwelche Arbeitsspeicher
Benchmark. Na gut, reinschreiben, lesen. Benchmark-Man. Du schreibst das rein und liest. Du kannst
das mit Cache in der CPU bedingt auch so machen. Da müsste ich mir mal Gedanken darüber machen,
wie ich einen CPU-Cache Benchmarken würde. Aber in der Regel kannst du auch Memory laden.
Du liest dann einfach schön viel Memory und liest dann aus. Das müsste doch eigentlich
ohne Probleme funktionieren. Den Old-School-ICQ-Messenger-Sound als Follower-Sound. Nee, du meinst hier A-oh.
Kannst du was sagen über RISC-V-Architektur gegenüber Arm-Line? Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Hast du schon mal etwas mit Open-Fast gemacht? Äh, nein. As-a-Service. Was ist es als As-a-Service?
Function-As-a-Service? Ist die Geschichte? Diese, diese, diese, diese Microservice-Dings-Geschichte,
die nicht Microservice heißt, war das das? Server des Functions, genau. Nee, habe ich
nichts mitgemacht. Habe ich nur mal einen, habe ich glaube ich mal einen Konferenztalk
zugekocht. Das haben wir schon. Ja, das waren alle Fragen oder habe ich jetzt irgendwas
übersehen? Ähm, zwingt dich, dass du einen Verlauf brauchst für deine Zwischenablage,
du wirst lachen. Ich habe einen Verlauf für meine Zwischenablage. Allerdings kopiere
ich meistens die gleichen Zahlen hintereinander, was dafür sorgt, dass es nur einen Eintrag
in der Zwischenablage gibt. Ach ja, welchen Mikrotik-Router? Warum steht denn das hier
nicht drin? Wahrscheinlich weil es abgekackt war, ne? Nutzt du die Emole-Vorschläge von
Discord? Ja klar. Also, machen wir als letztes noch einen Mikrotik-Router. Was hast du denn
so für Anforderungen an deinen Mikrotik-Router? Du willst einfach nur viele Ports haben? Hast
du irgendwie andere Wünsche, irgendwas wie 10G oder irgendwelche Layer-3-Plus-Funktionen
oder was? Was willst du damit machen? Also, wenn ich mir jetzt einen Gigabit, äh, wenn
ich mir jetzt einen Mikrotik-Switch kaufen würde, dann würde ich mir für 10G den hier
kaufen. Den da, der hat allerdings nur, ähm, 10G-Ports und ich glaube nicht einen Gigabit-Kopfer,
aber das kann man eh vergessen. Da habe ich übrigens noch einen da. Ich wollte eigentlich
ein Video dazu machen, habe ich mir mal gedacht, aber habe ich den gemacht, den habe ich immer
noch da. Einfach so. Ich habe, ich habe, hier Knäherbär, ich habe Steam-Profile gesigned.
Ja, wenn deins nicht gesigned ist, hast du es wahrscheinlich in Discord gepostet. Wenn
du es in Discord gepostet hast, habe ich es auch gesigned bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich
das, quasi die Emole drunter geschrieben habe. Wenn du danach bist, nachdem ich in den Channel
geschrieben habe, habe ich deins natürlich noch nicht gesigned. Als wären hier schon
die Ansprüche gestellt. Jetzt muss man es signen. Nicht so nach dem Motto, ich habe gesagt,
ich kann es euch mal sein. Jetzt muss, wenn das jetzt heute nicht gesigned ist, dann ist
die Anzeige direkt raus. Ähm, ok und mit mehr Ports, ja mit mehr Ports würde ich mir den
hier kaufen. Ich muss mal kurz gucken, welcher das war. Ja, was hast du so für eine Preis-Range?
Das ist nicht der, den ich kaufen würde. Der denn? Den da würde ich holen. Der ist nice.
Das ist ein sehr nicer Switch. Du hast 24 Gigabit Ports und zwei SFP Plus 10G Ports.
Den würde ich mir holen, wenn ich mir den anderen nicht holen würde. Also wenn ich
einen Switch bräuchte, all in one, der günstig ist, dann würde ich den holen. Mit dem kannst
du aber keine großartigen Sperenzchen machen, was Firmware angeht. Der hat auch nicht das
normale Router-OS von Mikrotik, der hat nur Switch-OS. Das heißt im Prinzip wirklich
nur Switching-Geschichten plus VLANs und sonst was. Also du kannst da keine Firewall-Regeln
machen, VPN-Geschichten machen, DHCP, Routing, wobei DHCP könnte funktionieren. Also wenn
du einfach nur einen Switch brauchst, der aber dafür gut ist, was Switch-Funktionen
angeht, die sind gut. Also der ist gut und den gibt es auch als Variante mit Router-OS
drauf. Genau, da kostet er noch ein bisschen mehr. Da kostet er so 40 Euro mehr oder 30-40
Dollar mehr. Ja, dann würde ich den nehmen. Dann würde ich den nehmen. Also wenn du auch
ein bisschen Routing-Geschichte damit machen willst, dann würde ich den nehmen. Ich meine,
das ist nicht der beste Router vor dem Herrn so. Also du kannst jetzt da nicht Gigabit-Dinger
routen. Ich meine, siehst du hier, Test Results, Routing, mach da mit ein paar Firewall-Rules,
mach da ein Gigabit ungefähr. Aber das reicht dir ja wahrscheinlich, dass du ein Gigabit
routen kannst. Das ist jetzt nicht viel, muss man sagen, für einen ordentlichen Router,
aber das reicht für den Heim-Gebrauch auf jeden Fall. Ja, dann würde ich den kaufen.
CS. Wie gesagt, den gleichen gibt es nur als reiner Switch. Den würde ich kaufen. Kostet
auch nur 100-170 Euro oder so. Ja, den würde ich holen. Preis-Leistungs-mäßig wirklich
perfekt. Geht kaum besser. Kommt dieses Jahr eigentlich noch ein YouTube-Video? Ja, kommt
noch. Ich habe mir ja vorgenommen, wieder welche zu machen. Okay Leute, es ist 1.25.50.
Ich gucke jetzt mal, ob irgendjemand on ist, den ich hosten kann. Von den, denen ich followe,
ein bisschen von den kleineren. Nope, keiner da. Den haben wir dann auf Twitch wieder.
Schauen wir mal, wie ich hoste, wird da irgendjemand, der dann vollkommen verwirrt ist, wie der
letztens sich dann extra festgestellt hat, dass er keine Hose anhat. Science and Technology.
Bastler-Nacht. Guck mal, der Bauten-Reisen-System. Der Bauten-Reisen-System, das ist doch mal
so. Hier baut er das zusammen. Okay, den haben wir sonst noch so. Roleplay. Die hosten
die mit dem Reisen-System. Das ist wenigstens was schönes Aktuelles. Und wir sehen uns
vielleicht morgen wieder. Machts gut, bis denn. See you.
Alter, was ist das für ein Scheiß? Lustig. Fail. Okay, Leute, keine Ahnung, was das für
eine große Spacke war.